Hello Freak pitches.
That's right.
My back.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you.
Buy naturebox.
Naturebox is a great way to get yummy food sent to you.
Yummy snack food.
You know,
a lot of us.
Um,
if I get hungry I will fuck up and I'll eat a snickers bar.
I will,
you know,
if I'm going to get an airport,
I don't like it,
but I'll do it every now and then.
I'd fucking hate myself.
I'll see something disgusting.
But when you have healthy stuff around that you could snack on your way more
likely to eat the healthy stuff.
As long as it's good healthy stuff.
The problem is usually options for me at least.
And this nature box stuff.
What I like about it is it gives you really good options and they're fucking
delicious.
Like I actually do choose them cause I like them.
The blueberry almonds,
all good googly Mowgli.
They're fucking delicious man.
They have this,
um,
these big apple pineapples I'm addicted to.
It's like there,
it's like just dried pineapple you can get,
you can get all sorts of like different food options.
Like,
if you,
if you're gluten free,
you can get gluten free,
you can get low sugar,
you can get a lot of different options too.
They've a lot of different stuff to choose from over a hundred different snacks
to choose from.
And um,
you know,
you can get like,
like if you need low sugar content,
if you have like dietary needs and whenever possible they try to use non GMO
food as well.
Uh,
there's no hydrogenated oils,
no high fructose corn syrup.
No Trans fats.
Which Brian,
what'd you say?
It was
fats with dicks.
Exactly.
So there's no trans fat,
no artificial sweeteners,
no artificial flavors,
no artificial colors.
It's actually like,
you know,
you could,
you don't have to feel bad about eating it.
The planting chips.
Oh my goodness,
they're good.
Woo.
Look,
uh,
you know,
people will be like,
oh,
they also have pretzels.
Yeah,
he could have pretzels too.
Pretzels and never good for you.
There's the news.
Okay.
It's not bad for you though.
It's not like,
you know all the other shit that I said.
All that stuff's bad.
Hydrogenated oils,
hydrogenated rather high fructose corn syrup.
That shit's terrible for you.
It Trans Fat.
It is all about options.
Honestly,
I don't ever go grocery shopping.
I go out to eat all the time.
So like when you're hungry at two in the morning at my house you got like
strawberries and cream,
oatmeal and chocolate syrup and and like edibles with weed and I'm so I usually
just go with the edibles that,
that we didn't fuck myself up on that you could hurt yourself and get injured.
There's a lot of good options.
They send me a new box every week and I'm pleasantly surprised that all the new
stuff,
the spicy pistachios are good too.
Those are very yummy.
You know what they have to do that they'll get the,
get the pistachios outside of the shell.
I know you can take him out of the shell bitch.
Okay.
Why are you playing games with me?
Why are you pretending that getting so many
pistachios?
Cause we both know that is a fucking pittance.
It's a pittance of pistachios in a pistachio back.
The could get all that extra shit.
You did get that fucking shallow off.
You know how to do it.
That's your fear.
Shit.
Doing that.
Trained to do that shit like open these little nuts.
I just want to eat them.
Yeah,
I'll pay for it.
I'll pay for you to open those nuts and cut the shit cause each one of those
takes a second of my life that I don't have time for.
I know I bought it before.
I've bought them in the fucking store.
Outside the shell and once you do that,
you go,
wait,
wait.
What the fuck are we been doing all these years?
So yeah,
you can eat the shit out of some pistachios if you get a big bag.
I got a bag of them the other day at the supermarket.
It was like a pillow.
I was like,
this is incredible.
That's what's been holding pistachios back.
Yeah.
Those stupid shells.
The flavors.
Sensational Pistachio in the th the nature box flavors.
Even better.
They have this spicy,
like a peppery pistachio.
Oh,
this is a limit.
Pucker pistachio.
They have Sriracha cashews to the Serratia.
Serratia.
How do you say that?
Saracha the stuff that,
uh,
that hot sauce with the chicken on it,
that delicious hot sauce.
They have cashews with that shit on it.
Oh my goodness.
It's good.
Anyway,
you go,
you'll go.
Now.
It's good for you,
my friends.
Good for you.
Every time we go to the UFC,
ra always gets like sunflower seeds or these kind of nuts and then by the time
we leave,
there's just a huge pile by his feet of these like,
yeah,
he's ridiculous.
He's like a bird.
When you get addicted to them,
man,
they're,
and they're actually very good for you.
They're high in protein.
Star shows are actually a guilt free snack,
believe it or not.
Anyway,
go to naturebox.com/rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan and you will get 50% off of
your first box by going there.
That's naturebox.com forward.
Slash.
Rolling.
We're also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is an all in one platform that allows you to easily create
professional websites online in literally minutes.
People say you're not supposed to say literally.
Yeah,
it's supposed to be figuratively,
but apparently they've actually changed the definition now because so many
idiots like me,
we use it incorrect.
They're like,
we give up,
right?
Because ultimately at the end of the day,
you know,
language only means what people want it to mean for people.
Agree that literally is a good way to say it.
It just gets beaten down and then people get upset.
The poor grammar,
it's not the poor grandma is that the grammar is growing.
Okay.
It's evolving.
You fucks and literally is a good way to say it,
but it's still hot.
It's figuratively,
eh.
Anyway,
Squarespace,
he all in one platform allows you to very easily create not just a website but a
web store.
Super easy to do.
Set it up real quick of your musician.
You can actually sell shit on there.
You can sell digital music and you could do all this like just setting it up
from your home computer.
If you know how to drag and drop,
if you know how to like attach photographs to an email,
all that easy shit.
You can use Squarespace.
You can do it.
Brian's doing it right now.
It's maybe about a hundred of these fucking things about photo drag and drop
content.
24,
seven support that we need an Ian Edwards.
Uh,
so what are you gonna do?
Cause we got Ari's one.
Well our is what,
what was the sexy legs already?
Sexy legs.com.
Sexy Lady.
Yeah,
it was whatever.
Don't go there.
If you're at work,
cause I don't know what Brian put on that fucking thing.
Anyway,
squarespace.com go there and enter the code word Joe for a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase.
That's squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
Squarespace also has a logo creator.
You can get a dope logo for Ian Edwards has small nipples.
That's just fucked.
It's real talk.
That doesn't hurt anybody's feelings.
If you say the nipples are small,
I mean I'll know what he goes.
What the fuck man?
You know,
you could tell someone their ears are small to get a little touchy.
like nobody likes ears.
Big Ears are too small.
I want to hear about all that.
Yeah,
you got a little nipples bro.
Like okay.
100% church out last night sitting outside looked over neighbor second floor up
place next to my house.
I was taking a shower and that it's an old windows old windows and the shower
type kind of houses had it like in step,
like maybe,
I don't know,
six inches and tits.
Jessalyn line where the tits are.
So I'm sitting at and I turned my chair around because it's dark outside and I
look over and I'm just like,
look.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
That's bet.
They're really,
really,
really fat tits and I'm just like watching like shampoo and soap and rubbing
them and stuff.
And I'm like,
all right,
this is horrible.
I'm just watching us and suddenly bends down.
It's a dude.
The whole time I'm watching.
It was a guy,
squarespace.com/
[inaudible] use the code word Joe,
squarespace.com enter in the code show the whole time he was masturbating and
meanwhile he's like,
he's living in the movie Porky's.
Anyway,
we're,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t m on it is a
human optimization website.
We sell shit that whatever it is,
whether it's a strength and conditioning equipment,
whether it's vitamins and nutrients,
we don't really sell vitamins.
We saw plant based nutrients more than we sell vitamins and we still have,
um,
we'd have like a,
a vitamin C and lysine supplement.
But I think pretty much everyone who is involved in a health and nutrition
recommends that if you're going to take any sort of vitamin,
you should definitely take something that's food based,
meaning not something that's artificially synthesize,
but something that has extracted from plants.
It's probably one of the best ways to go about supplementing nutrients,
but the very best way is always your diet.
And people don't like to hear that shit.
They want to just be able to pop some pills and eat a cheeseburger.
But the reality of just most of our diets is most likely were nutritionally
deficient.
It sucks.
It's not the way to do it.
You're,
you're definitely better off if you eat healthy food.
But my reality,
and I bet your reality too,
is that sometimes you don't have time for that shit.
If you're a busy person,
sometimes it's hard to eat correct and things like this,
the earth grown nutrients that we uh,
we have that we sell is,
it's a great way to supplement just to make sure that you're kind of covering
your nutritional basis.
Because if you don't,
shit goes wrong and that's just how it works.
The human body is just like a fucking machine,
new net man.
It's a series of organisms all boring together in one ecology that's called your
life for us.
But whatever it is,
it needs fuel.
And if you give it the shit fuel,
it works.
Shitty and shitty things break and they go wrong.
And that's just the way it is.
I mean,
that's the way it is.
If you don't take care of your body,
the more you can do to give your body the building blocks,
the very things that extracts from food to make itself.
I mean,
the reason why we have cells at all,
the reason why your body works at all,
it's getting something from food that gives it the fuel to grow.
And the better that fuel without a doubt,
the better the quality of the body it's able to construct and whether it's
health or wellbeing or just even how your brain works,
man,
try eating.
If you don't know,
man,
you just eat.
If you're a healthy eater,
eat shitty food every fucking day,
all day for a month and see how stupid you feel.
Just feel dumb.
All slowed down,
caked up and clogged up with shit.
But if you eat healthy,
you get addicted to it.
Um,
that's my on it.
Inspirational message about food for the day.
I'll email.
The reason why I say this is I wish someone said it to me when I was younger.
I wish I,
I wish someone had made sense out of it.
So if I feel like I'm harping on it too much,
I feel like I'm harping on it to me too.
But if one person hears that and just stops and thinks about what they're doing
to their meat wagon,
you know,
I mean,
so many people treat their meat wagon like shit,
get that bitch and shape,
give it some nutrient and give it a good workout.
Let that fucking thing express itself.
Pump out some hormones.
Just do it.
Blow it out of your system.
Get that,
get rid of that stress.
You're not supposed to be in a fucking cubicle.
Dude,
I got news for you.
That shit ain't normal.
You're not supposed to be sitting in the same chair all fucking day staring at
an artificial light that shit's dot normal.
And if you don't give your body som primal shit,
some throwing some weights around some grunting or running up hills to simulate
being chased by predators and I bang the sex count,
sex counts,
especially if you do it the way you do it.
Right?
Brian's letting those why looking at a man that wasn't I.
So it was a warmup that just makes him,
you know,
reconsider his whole stance about,
uh,
trannies and such.
You're not even allowed to say trainings and such,
they'll get upset at you if you do that.
Transgender people,
my apologies.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t check out the long line of strength and
conditioning equipment that we carry.
We carry now I'm two different types of artistic kettlebells,
the Zombie bells in the prime of bells.
But if you're a no nonsense type of motherfucker,
we sell regular kettlebells to redesigned.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
um,
we,
uh,
we wanted to have a larger,
handle gaps.
Um,
so you could,
uh,
you could really move the,
the bells around a bit better.
I like them with the larger,
like it's,
there's two schools of thought when it comes to these things.
Um,
one school of thought is that the other ones are more difficult,
hence better to workout with because they're more difficult to move around.
And the other one is that competition kettlebells,
which have a much larger handle,
meaning more space.
It's still fat.
It's a big fat handle,
which is really good too because you want that for like an enhancing your grip
strength.
But that I'm with the larger handle,
there's more room for movement.
So you could get your proper technique better.
Your hand sort of slip into the,
uh,
the holes where the Kettlebell handle this better.
So I've heard both schools of thought and I think both have some merit to it.
The kind of user,
not like this.
I use the kind with a smaller opening and uh,
like,
cause I use the,
um,
the original dragon door ones is where I got mine and I have the a on at once
too.
And I feel like,
uh,
they're,
they're all important.
It's like,
it's not a bad thing to use the competition ones and uh,
you know,
the competition size handle.
But it's not a bad thing to use like that gorilla either.
You know,
it's awkward.
And I think anytime you're putting yourself in a position where you're doing
strength and conditioning work,
you should do both.
You should do with proper form and you should do also do some awkward shit too.
Like sandbag stuff.
I like doing an awkward shit.
Like it's,
cause it's,
it's extra frustrating while you're doing it.
And that sounds ridiculous and like,
like I'm a masochist,
but I feel like there's certain workouts,
it's good to be able to voluntarily push through discomfort,
you know?
I don't want everything.
They always feel perfect.
I like getting callouses.
I don't wear gloves.
I like throwing sandbags around.
I like,
I don't mind if I'm lifting weights and it ripped skin on my hand.
I feel I'm fucking doing something,
you know,
I'm here to get to work.
I'm not scared of getting scratched and uh,
so I like both.
I like doing things with proper form.
That's the most important thing.
If you're thinking about working out and you've never done it before,
you're like,
this is it.
I'm getting my fucking body in shape.
Go slow.
Whatever you do,
get a trainer if you can,
if you can afford to have someone show you how to do the move movements properly
and if you can videotape yourself,
that's a good one too.
If not,
if you can't afford that,
if you lived nowhere where there's a trainer that you trust or you maybe have
trust issues and you want to work on your own,
you can do it,
but please do it slowly.
Um,
there's plenty of goto information,
um,
how to rather information on,
on at.com.
That's o,
n n I t but there's also a bunch online.
Uh,
Steve Maxwell,
our friend who has,
um,
been on the podcast before who's just a brilliant kettle bell and fitness
instructor.
He has a lot of great stuff online.
Maxwell a strength and conditioning.com.
Maxwell S it might be Steve Maxwell,
Steve Maxwell,
SC,
is it Maxwell se or Steve Maxwell,
Maxwell Maxwell.
His Twitter name is Steve Maxwell,
SC and his website is Maxwell s c.com.
He's got a lot of stuff that you can download,
a really brilliant digital downloads of his,
uh,
all of his exercises and exercise routine.
He,
so he's a real stickler for form and the dude's a,
just a real fitness expert and just awesome,
awesome guys.
Well,
and a big proponent of the kettle bells anyway.
Enough on a.com use the codeword Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements he
and motherfuck gain Edward.
Cue The music.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Yeah.
Powerfully.
And what's up buddy?
How are you man,
man,
good to see you too.
Always good to have you on man.
You know I've told you the story.
Yeah,
you told me the story.
It's mind boggling.
It's bananas.
So I guess I'll kind of repeat it and then we'll,
well yeah,
please do.
Yeah,
but people need to hear this.
This is,
this is
odd.
All right.
So,
uh,
I'm in the middle of selling my house.
I had an escrow,
uh,
and uh,
they told me to move out in 45 days,
45,
the 45th days today.
Monday.
So I moved the entire weekend and as I pull up and get out the car to come into
the studio,
I get a phone call from the real estate agent telling me that the loan for the
buyer didn't go through.
So I'm,
I'm moved out.
My stuff is in storage.
I gave half of it away to this Mexican church across the street from me and I
got shit all over the place.
I don't have an address.
Oh my goodness.
You know,
I'm supposed to be staying on a friend's couch.
I'm just scared that I'm just,
I'm just all over the place right now and I'm,
and I'm coming in here,
you know,
to have some and do the show and chase shut it down.
Oh,
the reason why they shut it down though,
it's fascinating.
Okay,
so they stopped the buyer's loan because they don't like the buyers answer for
where their funds that they are having.
The account came from,
like the buyer has enough money to back the loan,
but they don't,
they think it's fishy.
They don't like where the monies come from,
the answers or where the money's from.
So they said,
well,
we're not going to going to sign off on this loan because we don't like your,
your money.
What?
You know what sometimes people do apparently is a,
they'll get family members to deposit money in account to make the account look
really big.
Right?
And then they go for a loan.
They check the account and they go,
oh,
there's all this money in there,
but they just move it out as soon as he gets it.
Like the only reason why it's in there is to make the loan.
They're going to give him a little piece of the action to make the loan go
through.
That can get tricky,
you know?
Apparently.
Yeah.
I guess you have to show how much you make.
I mean,
if you make $100,000 a year,
but you got $50 million in the bank,
they're going to go,
fuck's going on dude?
Hey,
saving my money.
Now that that doesn't seem to make sense,
man.
Chase has been in the news a lot lately for a knocking down a lot of anything.
Adult Entertainment,
like even shutting down a condom store that just sold condoms online because it
had something to do with the adult industry.
It's incredible.
It's incredible that a condom thing,
like birth control is dirty.
LikeW we will be waiting for 10 and we all fuck.
Is that what's going on here?
Are we pretending we don't have sex and we pretend that we don't like to fuck.
If somebody doesn't like the fuck,
I don't want to talk to you.
All right.
You're a Weirdo.
Fucking is half of what people love to do in life.
They shut down a condom store.
Yeah.
Chase banks do business with me because I run a condom company.
Very few people enter into relationships with men and women not wanting to ever,
fuck.
It's always a part of the thing that they want to do.
Like the happiest,
most in love.
People like still like to have sex with each other,
right?
Like there's nothing wrong with condoms.
The idea that there's something wrong with birth control is saying that there's
something wrong always with sex.
It's so stupid.
Chase.
One day it'd be more people so they can turn down.
Is that,
is that what they're doing?
They want people have more kids and they say,
no,
you can't get this loan.
Dude,
you're your bit about what's not.
Uh,
I don't want to give it away because if you,
you got to see Ian Live like for folks who don't know,
I think you get slept on man.
I really do.
I think you're one of the best comics in the world.
Appreciate that.
And,
and I've known that for a long time,
man.
You've always been really fucking funny and I think you're,
you're,
you're starting to pick up steam right now and it's awesome to see.
But that bit you have on bankers.
Dude,
I don't want to say anything about the bugs.
I don't want people to go see it.
I fucking love that bit.
God Damn,
that's good.
I'm going to,
I'm going to be doing it with extra venom
when you see me.
Maybe just going to be really emotional time.
I do it.
Are you around Wednesday night?
Uh,
something's going on.
What is the Wednesday?
Oh,
I was going to go to the store for Gerard's thing.
What is it?
Uh,
he's taping.
Is Hbo Album this HBO special?
Oh,
what time is that?
Probably.
Probably at night.
Ish.
At night if sheer like eight ish.
Yeah.
What time you got to do it 10 too.
I haven't even,
I haven't even booked it yet.
How about that?
You can roll like that though.
You got to do is get on.
That's,
that's the beauty of Twitter and all that.
You're just like,
Bam.
Just,
just put out a tweet and Bam.
It's on.
It's also that I get guys like Ian Edwards would come and do the show.
You know DNS is going to be on to,
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We'll him Z as an,
I had a great time in Santa Barbara.
God Damn Santa Barbara is awesome.
Here we go over there.
Yeah,
I've been over there.
It's like I don't want people to know about it.
I feel about it.
I don't like to talk about Santa Barbara on,
on,
on a podcast,
so they don't want people to hear about it.
I don't want them to hear about it.
I fucked up.
I should have shut my mouth.
Solaris.
I really should've shut my mouth that places.
It's sweet.
It's only like 100,000 so people up there,
it's great.
They're all real cool,
friendly people.
There's no fucking traffic.
There's some on the highway.
You get off the highway
five o'clock everybody's just traveling around like normal
damn.
And you go,
oh wait a minute,
this is possible.
You could live somewhere where you could just get somewhere at five o'clock you
don't have to.
I was talking to this lady at this,
uh,
this doctor's office.
She told me that she lives in Hollywood and she works in Santa Monica and
sometimes when she leaves at night it takes her an hour and 45 minutes to get
home as believable.
I actually think she's lying in it.
It takes a long,
that's
fucking insane.
That's insane.
And he'd go to,
you ever go like Big Sur?
You ever been in a place like that?
It's up,
up in northern coast,
heard of it,
but I'd never been up there.
A lot of writers like hunter s Thompson lived there,
Miller lived there.
A lot of writers go there because it's so stunning that they just,
it's kind of a little bit dour.
Like the air is wet.
It gets fucking cold sometimes cause it's a lot of like wind and shit from the,
the moist waves and yeah,
there's a lot of moisture,
but it's northern California.
But God damn,
it's fucking beautiful.
And it helps him,
right?
Yeah.
But you go to a place like that where there's not as many people as la and you
realize you could just get anywhere.
You start thinking like,
what am I doing?
Like what,
what is it,
what's the point in living in this cramp spot?
Is it because there's a lot of my friends here,
but why?
Why do people choose to do this?
I'm trying to think of somewhere I went to do a show.
It's kind of in wine country.
I'll like Sonoma,
like update something like that.
It's just this little,
what's that place you go to?
Sylvane Sylvane that's awesome.
It's like east,
uh,
Santa Barbara and she just,
it looks like if Disney,
a town in
the middle of nowhere,
like a small little warnings like windmills everywhere.
There's ostrich farms that are this awesome.
And there's tons of wineries.
He'd just get drunk and hang out in this creepy little town.
I have to turn it into Brian's.
Well that's what does and wine tasting things.
No,
no,
no.
We'll gentlemen getting fucked up.
Fancy drunk gentleman.
Oh yeah.
He trick your Nigga get becoming drunks.
They even sell it to like buy like these big two liters and these huge course of
things when you go to the winery,
when she first,
did you see that shit about a Jim Cook?
Jim Cook,
the guy who makes Sam Adams?
No,
he,
he uh,
he was expressing how you can eat brewer's yeast and it keeps you from getting
drunk.
Like yeah,
pull it up,
man.
Jim Cook,
uh,
explains how to drink beer all night and not get drunk.
It's really kind of fascinating man.
Like he figured out some sort of biochemical process that you can sort of create
in your body and helps your body process alcohol better.
It's interesting because I'm very yeasty,
it's been proven by many doctors and stuff like that.
So that might be why I can drink so much proven.
It's been proven that I'm very easy.
Here's the studies brings over fucking
things from at Sam Adams founder Jim Koch.
I think it's coke says a spoonful of yeast makes them less drunk.
Jim Classroom Cook is a cook.
Yeah.
Why not spell it?
Cook.
Why you making me work so hard?
We can't change it.
Change a little symbols to what we all mutually agree upon.
It looks like coke.
Yeah,
let's change it.
Like,
you know,
they changed literally.
Yeah.
They have changed that to coke because it's not coke or good is coke.
It's not cook.
I don't care what your parents call it.
Spelling it wrong dude.
That's what I was like.
Oh,
like the Koch brothers,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
Cool.
How does,
you know the Koch brothers that live in that building?
It's spelled the same way as that,
right?
Yeah.
K.
O c.
H.
So how come it could be two different things?
Isn't that cook?
The cook brothers,
the coke,
those uh,
those rich guys.
Billionaires and it's k.
O.
C.
H.
Yeah,
I think so.
You could look it up.
I don't,
I don't even know why people argue anymore.
Like people are still having the arguments,
like Google doesn't exist when somebody asks me a question then we saw going
back.
Yeah,
let's,
let's just Google it.
I've,
I've been humbled by Google many times.
It just,
it forces you to recognize like what are we doing when we argue sometimes about
being right or wrong,
it's so stupid.
So like if you know something and I don't know it,
why should I care?
You know,
why does anybody care?
And if you do,
if somebody asks you something,
you don't know the answer,
why would you bullshit?
It's a greater tendency to d two bullshit.
Like there's something else going on.
It's eagle.
Yeah,
it's really annoying.
you gotta cut it out.
So I got to go to and the world and swallow gotta cut it down by Google.
But there's also a lot of ridiculous websites you can get caught up in the mix
and some of them have lives.
It's also like studies,
like,
like one study will say it's good for you,
another study we'll say it gives you Dick Cancer.
Like,
can you guys figure this out?
It's like a bunch of different guys claiming to be the welterweight champion of
the world.
Like he can't have five different welterweight champions.
Just like you can't have,
you know,
you can't.
You've got to figure it out.
Let us know.
Okay,
we'll wait.
And that's when you say welterweight champion meeting boxing.
That's why boxing,
it's not what it used to be
used to be really ridiculous.
There was like a gang,
I don't know if there's as many now.
You always hear about the big ones,
the WBC,
WBA,
IBF.
Those are the big ones.
And then that was the Ibo was an,
that came along.
There was a,
there's a bunch of different ones too.
One time I was welterweight champion
for my sister.
Did you see the my Donna fight?
Nah,
they were there.
My Donna,
I refuse to watch,
uh,
maybe where the fight until he fights pack out.
I think everyone,
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm boycotting them doing my,
Donna made a hell of a fight out of it.
A lot of fun.
Yeah.
It was a great fight.
It was fun if you know how they played on HBO the next week,
if you're fully moved back into wherever you
turned off their cable box on Saturday.
Oh,
that's crazy.
Crazy bananas.
Not know that it could go like me neither.
I thought that once a deal's a deal,
like the paperwork starts getting moving.
I didn't know you could just stop the process.
Yeah.
If the bank,
I thought they were going to close.
They even tried to close early the other day and I said,
I won't be out,
but they had to approve it at one point they had.
They approved it.
Yeah.
And then someone like overside somebody oversized,
Eh,
we don't trust these Persians.
I want to find out what they did.
Yeah.
I need to and support it and somehow give him more money.
So you got a way to circumvent the system.
You're probably selling something good.
Oh man,
that's the Irene.
It was probably something that would like it probably sell.
I'm awesome.
Maybe it's raw milk.
Marijuana.
It could be marijuana.
Whatever it is.
Fucking let's leave them alone.
It's all the money from those rug stores as millions and millions of rug stores
that you see everywhere in your like how did,
that's a serious crime though.
You're trying to hide income hiding incomes is serious crime apparently.
Cause you really think about it like hiding income,
you know,
if you got a lot of cash coming in and how much,
like what a percentage of how much you actually make is like under the table
that you would get taxed on,
you know,
and how much more money would the government get because of that.
And how much of an example can they make out of you to make sure that someone
hears about it so they don't do it right.
It's just fucking
in Italy.
Dolce and Gabbana probably going to jail really.
Like right now they got like,
uh,
18 months suspended sentence but it's for hiding money offshore.
Ah.
And it's like,
like could you imagine dolce and Gabbana in jail?
That is just bananas.
And that's like the perfect example of what you're talking about.
Like making an example of somebody that everybody knows who you,
you would think never would go to jail.
If they do it to them,
then they,
yeah,
they don't fuck around when it comes to that.
That's the most mafia shit in the world is the tax collector.
Yeah,
because they don't treat it like it's money.
They take away your freedom.
It's one of the rare times where just it becomes a crime.
Well,
you're not giving someone enough money that'd becomes a crimes,
bananas,
bliss.
But it just,
it becomes a crime that they go after you with a fucking fever that's reserved
for terrorism.
Yeah.
I mean they'll put your ass in jail,
could have done everything right all your life and just throw in one extra
receipt in there.
Well then I don't think it's that much,
but if they find out,
you're probably pretty fair about finding out whether or not you're actually
being a tax cheat.
But if you are a tax cheat,
they fucking go after you.
Like what they did with Wesley Snipes.
He,
they wouldn't even let him pay it.
They wouldn't even let them pay Lauren Hill in jail.
They're like,
well,
you got to go to jail.
No,
no,
no.
You're going to go to fucking jail.
They put Lauren Hill and jail.
She's a menace to society.
Yeah.
The singer songwriter,
she's a mess.
She's out there singing.
She's like,
I'll give you two of the grammys.
you didn't even make enough money.
He didn't give me enough money,
so we're going to have to lock you in a cage.
That's crazy.
Especially when you say cage,
we're going to lock you in a cage.
That's what it is.
I'm gonna pay you and I,
I firmly believe that we should all pay taxes firmly believe it.
I really do.
I think we need to pay what we didn't figure out what's important for everybody.
What's,
what's number one?
Is it healthcare?
What's number two?
Is it,
is it,
is it school systems?
Like what?
What are,
what are our priorities?
Figuring out what the,
and then figure out how much that shit costs.
Like get people who really know what they're doing and everybody should
contribute their part.
At least what you can contribute.
It would make the world a better place.
Right?
That's what we all want.
But it gets real squirrely went,
I don't know what you're doing with that money
real squarely within it because it's fucked up on so many ends.
Like some people don't want to dishonest and don't want to pay it into some Po.
When they get the money,
they blow it on shit.
So then that justifies that.
The people who don't want to pay,
they're like,
look what they just did with that.
And then there's some people not getting enough of it who needed like for
education,
especially like in the hood and all that Shit.
It's like,
and it's like this shit is all fucked up and it's dishonest people in if there's
a Pi cutting five and that could make this thing work.
There's this honest people in each slice.
Well I think we would all be happy to pay taxes,
but I think,
I think people would be way more likely to pay taxes if we had a better sense of
community and if they know where the fucking
mind is going like this.
No receipt.
We don't get a receiver.
Hey,
you know,
you paid Ian,
you paid x amount of money and you know this amount went to school systems.
You'd be happy to know that this amount,
one to fix the streets,
you'd be happy to know.
That would be beautiful.
If we got a chance to see that,
you know,
you'd,
you'd be able to look at it like quantify,
look,
you know,
my,
the fruits of my work have sent x amount of dollars towards public education.
That would be a nice feeling.
And you know why it's not transparent and there's no receipt because it's not
being distributed equally and that would fuck people up.
Well,
it's fucked up that it's not art.
It's not only is it not our call,
it's pretty,
we're in the dark about it hardly ever comes up.
When people talk about the budget,
it's always a balancing of the budget.
The president's attempting to balance a budget.
They're adjusting bills and the balancing of the
budget.
Very important voice.
I like to important voice that.
Yeah,
that's how they talk.
I'm about to tell you.
So I'm about to tell you nothing that's important.
Voice balancing knocked the purchases.
He must be right.
That's not the president addresses the nation this evening.
The president's hype,
man,
it's so president.
Well,
all that
fake shit that used to exist in like the fucking bicentennial days back in the
17 hundreds and shit.
It's like still going on in that way.
There's a formal way of communicating like we don't need that anymore.
We don't do.
There should never be a formal time where you communicate because all that means
is that there's a bunch of shit you're not going to tell me and I'm not going to
know how you really thinking.
I'm going to hear some thing that I allow you to do where you go into this fake
speaker voice and I'll allow you to say a bunch of stupid shit with no,
I don't.
No one gets to talk to you.
You don't have to communicate like that anymore.
It doesn't.
The only reason that used to exist because you had to get like a bunch of people
hear ye hear ye
your phones.
So the yelling out to some fucking room,
they have to yell it out cause you can't just talk and then people can't talk
back to you who's not.
There's too many of them would take too much time.
Fuck it.
But now,
now it doesn't.
Now there's a way like there's,
it's like there's interaction should be,
it should be like this would be some sort of a
two way street.
You should be 2014 type of style interaction instead of what they're doing right
now.
The important thing is that the president has let us know where the money goes
back to you.
Who are you?
Why are you talking like that?
The president is crazy.
They're crazy.
Everyone's crazy coffee from the guy before you who did that job before.
Our country is strong.
Our will.
It's great
magic.
If you're eating and someone started talking,
he like that.
You're in the middle of dinner.
If someone starts to do you like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Dinner on the floor.
Weird asshole talking like this.
This is crazy.
Talk telling me how I feel and how are we gonna make it through this.
You're going to tell me how I'm going to make it through this and you're going
to disappear after the speech go
away.
Crazy.
When is that going to go away?
I mean at one point in time they had to get rid of the powdered wigs.
Okay.
So at one point in time those judges were
wearing those wigs and they're like,
look,
we got to have the wigs were not wearing the web was this shit is no good.
That was bananas.
That's how shit was when a motherfucker,
you know,
when I was telling you what was up here,
Ye hear you.
And he's just like a squire wearing high heels or wearing,
wearing high heels.
That's wear high heels came from,
oh I started it and robes at one point in time someone had a look at that and
go,
Yo,
we gotta stop this.
Stop with the wigs.
And they fought.
This is tradition.
It's always been
terrible.
Alvers still a documentary about the fucking,
the revolt to keep the wigs on.
Holy Shit.
Well spoke up in England and court like you get sentenced by more fucking a wig.
I was still doing like so crazy.
Oh,
you guys want me to not listen.
Listen,
there's nothing I can do about this or are you going to tell me this shit like a
man?
Take Her fucking Waco for you telling me I got 25 years.
Oh,
I'm not doing it.
I'm going to try to escape.
Take that fucking wig off right now.
What are you doing?
Stupid.
Why are you dressing like you're in a different time era?
Show you put on a show for me.
You have a wig on.
This is a show.
This is a God damn play.
Absolutely.
Where's the other people in the play experience?
No real.
You're putting on a play
Solaris.
So ridiculous.
Can we see some,
can you pull up some modern English court Gyn Wig?
What do they call him?
A Barista Barista.
The was a barrister.
A um,
a Gr a lawyer.
There's not a lawyer.
That's the old school.
That's old school.
See if you can find some,
that's John Belushi,
that weird fucking scene.
So that was one of those scenes.
You can't really,
you can't really do that,
man,
I'll ever,
stone wasn't there.
While that was going down,
like man,
you took a little creative license and then need to talk to you about it.
You don't even have any pictures of these guys doing this.
How do you know that then went down like that?
That's what he does,
what they did.
Oh,
okay.
All right man.
This is like,
there's a lot of people like have a problem with Oliver Stone because of shit
like that.
Like you know that movie Jfk,
you know with the Donald Sutherland character comes over and tells all the
information,
all the details you met,
you know that scene?
Yeah.
Apparently that dude,
he,
he made up that guy.
He made up that guy that wasn't like an historical guy.
He was used as like a tool to sort of propel the story along.
That's,
this is what I had heard.
Forget parts of JFK.
I can't even remember that part.
It was an interesting,
I need to pull it up now and make sure Donald Sterling's character because I did
just say that now and I'm saying as I said it,
I'm like,
I maybe I'm wrong.
Not Donald Sterling,
Donald Sutherland,
Jonathan,
Donald Sterling,
some braids.
I saw Donald Sutherland the other day,
man.
I was watching the old school invasion of the body snatchers Jeff,
long time ago.
Jeff gold blooms in it.
He's 20 years old.
Looks like a little kid.
It's crazy.
I just saw him in a hotel,
Budapest or some shit like that.
While you're here,
if you Google Donald Sutherland and then write scene scene,
JFK comes up and immediately pull it up.
Brian,
he says JFK movie clip.
Yeah.
Donald Sutherland seen JFK movie clip.
Sit on a bench together.
It's a fee.
It's a fascinating thing because if this,
if this guy didn't really exist,
then yeah,
that one right there.
If this guy didn't really exist,
like it's,
it's a vehicle to distribute the truth,
but
the truth of special,
I think it's supposed to be as inner dialogue.
No,
no,
but listen,
because this is a guy
who's telling him all this stuff.
One of my routine duties,
if I had been in Washington,
would have been to arrange for additional security in Texas,
so I decided to check it out.
Sure enough,
I found out that someone had told them 112 to military intelligence group,
the Fourth Army headquarters at Fort Sam Houston to stand down that day over the
protests of the unit commander Colonel,
I believe it's a mistake.
This is significant because it is standard operating procedure,
especially in uno and hostile.
I said just something with the secret service men.
Even if we had not allowed them to be remote,
we would have placed at least 100 to 200 agents on the sidewalk.
Without question,
Stevenson spit on him.
I'd already been several attempts under God's life in France.
We would have arrived days ahead of time,
never cover the area.
That's just whole clip.
They had been on the radio.
We'd been watching.
Just let it go for a couple
of
army presence in the streets.
It was a violation of the most basic protection codes.
Who could invest gun,
this black ox,
Mr. Garrison.
People in my business,
people like nice very officer could've called Colonel Back and said,
look,
we have another unit coming from so and so providing security.
You'll stand out.
I mean that day.
In fact,
there were some individual in Dallas and still trying to figure out why,
but they weren't protecting client.
And of course,
awesome army intel,
Ivy Lee Oswald on file,
all those files and destroyed.
Thanks.
Strange things were happening.
Anyway,
here's the point.
If that guy didn't really say all that Shit,
are you allowed to just do that?
I think that's how all of a stone feels about the situation.
He just wanted to get his shit across.
Well,
you pay.
He says the guy's a real guy.
Oliver Stone says,
the guy's name is Fletcher Prouty,
p,
r,
O,
u,
t wife,
Fletcher Prouty.
And then he served in the military since World War II and from 55 to 64 who was
in the Pentagon working as a chief of special operations.
Hmm.
So apparently it was a real dude.
According to Oliver Stone.
I saw a dope JFK movie.
I forgot it's called park something.
Did anybody see it now?
What is it?
It's uh,
it came out last year.
It's about an earliest.
It's about,
it's about the assassination,
but it's about everybody around it.
It's about,
it's about the,
the secret service.
Like said he gets shot and before they show the hospital and the doctors in the
hospitals.
So it's about them operating on JFK.
Parkland.
Yeah.
Parkland,
a fight for his body with the corner in the city to get in the body on the
plane.
Then there was a part where the CIA agent agent is like,
uh,
listen,
we got to protect the president and they're looking at JFK.
And the guy said,
okay,
let's do it.
And they said,
that's not the president anymore.
Like when they taken his body out of the,
the topless car to put him in the ambulance and the secret,
the secret service guy looked at his brain.
He's like,
that dude's not the president anymore.
And then it was about grabbing,
uh,
the vice president and securing him and said,
we got to get him back on the plane and everybody associated.
And then they said,
what about the first lady?
And she's like,
the night she ain't the first lady no more.
And it was like ready to just,
it's like those moments like they,
they're like ready to those like catcher to the wall.
It's like,
but it was just protocol and it's just like,
so it was about the shit that they went through.
The doctor's like trying to resuscitate and their day and,
and then Sapir Ooda who had to film and then getting the film from him.
And it was,
it was well done.
It was underrated.
There was a bunch of witnesses to the assassination,
people that were in the grassy knoll,
people that were in that area.
Out of those people in a three years from the time of the murder,
the three year period,
18 witnesses were killed,
six by gunfire,
three by motor accidents too by suicide,
one from a cut throat,
one from a karate chop,
the neck,
three from heart attacks.
And two from natural causes.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
I want
more info on the karate chop to the name.
Yeah.
How do they know it was a karate
chop?
Cried shops are rarely fatal.
Maybe the guy was a bitch to the neck though.
I just saw that a myth busters last night.
They were talking about how you could I actually be driving on a motorcycle at
certain speeds and hit the right kind of bug at the right kind of place on your
throat and it could just kill you.
Wow.
Just from politics.
It was that.
It was one of those huge like almost beetle bugs that are only in like Africa,
you know?
But they look like like a,
like almost like a dinosaur bug.
You know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
They do fly the holy shit.
What am I,
are they pull that up?
I got to tell Dean Darry to look out.
Yeah.
That seems like you get hurt,
man.
Other countries do way worse than us when it comes to bugs.
We're lucky when it comes to bugs,
especially California.
That's one thing you know,
realize you go back east during the summer and you'd get walked on by
mosquitoes,
so you go,
oh yeah,
you guys have bugs everywhere.
Like what country are we in?
California?
They killed all their books.
If you go to Florida,
go to Gainesville,
Florida in July.
It's like,
good luck.
It doesn't even feel like America southern fucking truck.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Chaotic,
Goliath.
Beautiful.
I think that's a real bug.
Oh my God.
It's a crap.
Is her hand small or is that the room?
That hand?
Yeah.
Here's another one of them.
Whoa.
Get the fuck out.
This thing for folks who,
it's like a picture.
Your grandfather's flip phone.
Not Not your mom's flip phone,
but your grandfather's legacy.
Motorola.
STARTAC.
That's what it's like.
It looks like a bit dazzled phone case,
I think.
What?
Fuck you up.
That's a big bug.
I've got this thing.
I think we'd have to pry her mouth open.
Ooh.
Oh,
that's a ocean creature,
isn't it?
I don't think at all.
That's the beetle is not a water beetle is the giant a sauce pot.
Oh my God.
It's technically not an insect,
but what the fuck?
Technically not an insect.
What is it then?
What do you find those?
I bet that's a delicious lobster to
look like a lobster tail,
didn't it?
Yeah.
Well that's what a bug is,
man.
I mean,
the lobsters are bugs.
There's just bugs in the water.
They can swim.
They're very similar to cockroaches.
In fact,
we found out on fear factor that if you're allergic to shellfish,
you're also allergic to cockroaches.
Oh,
for real.
We found that out the hard way.
Oh,
Shit.
Yeah.
Somebody gets sick.
Well,
we found out that this dude had eaten these,
uh,
cockroaches and his throat started to close up.
You start having allergic reaction.
He can't breathe.
You have to give you,
I think it's a shot of adrenaline or something like that.
Yeah.
If you're allergic,
you got to tell people everything you're allergic to or you can't.
He can't hide things just to try to win $50.
I don't know what happened there.
Maybe.
Maybe somebody asks shellfish.
Yes.
And they didn't bother asking bugs.
Maybe they didn't know.
Yeah.
That does live in the water.
Is that it looks like an alien thing is crazy.
So it lives in the water and not only does it look at alien,
it looks like a spacecraft.
Looks like an alien head look.
So really that's so ridiculous that that's a real animal.
He's got gold it,
it's got gold eyes,
everything.
It's about a hamburger.
I don't know.
No,
it's way bigger than that.
That thing was like a football,
uh,
here.
What I did was holding an earlier,
yeah,
that was more football sized masterclass.
How unprofessional is if I run to the bathroom at all,
dude,
it happens all the time.
Nobody there's expects to to hang.
Oh,
here we go.
The deep sea.
I suppose it's right through there.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at that thing.
And this was all right.
How would you describe her?
And it's not quite a full Mullen,
it looks like a huge lobster tail and huge.
So I've been soaking up pill bug,
remove the formalin since that's kind of nasty.
Like the biggest lobster today is size of a football shape of a drying out,
get it set up to dry out and assessment out of it.
We're so weird though.
Why would that be gross to us?
So the first thing I'm going to do,
why would that be gross?
We eat lobster.
Like if we were at a restaurant and I ordered lobster,
would you get grossed out
when it,
when I'm eating lobster I just went the other day and had it and it's still kind
of freaks me out.
And like I,
it was like I had it for lunch,
I had lobster tail for lunch and I could only eat at poppa doughs in Phoenix and
I could only eat half of it.
I just got sick almost like I,
it just hit w wrong.
Like I have to be in the mood after it has to be later in the day and I can't
have any hangover then.
I just won't think about it.
Maybe you just have a weird thing with it cause I just think lobsters.
Delicious.
Yeah,
I've never thought about it.
And then when you see their light and hairs and up here in the head,
I had some shrimp cocktail the other day and uh,
I can't imagine that anybody doesn't like it here.
Yeah.
I can't imagine that people don't like shrimp cocktail.
But Jamie didn't want to have the shrimp cocktail.
Jamie.
He's like,
no,
I didn't do it.
Wow.
And he's not in any water.
Bugs.
Doesn't eat the water bugs.
I'll eat street meat.
I'll eat lobster.
Look,
shrimps are delicious.
This,
there's nothing wrong with you,
Jamie.
You're the problem.
Not the shrimps.
Shrimps a magical creatures that tastes so good and they're one of those
creatures where you don't feel so bad about killing them and eating them.
You know,
very few.
Like if you,
Karl Malone shot a bear,
there's a photo on Tmz of Karl Malone with it
bear that he shot and everybody was getting upset.
Um,
shot it with bow and Arrow and,
um,
you know,
that,
that freaks people out.
But if he was eating a bowl of shrimp,
nobody would give a fuck.
I'm more weird.
Lately I found out that was it.
Jellyfish.
No,
no,
no octopus.
Awkward pauses are almost as smart as a,
yeah.
Dolphins.
And so I'm thinking like,
Shit,
I know people that don't octopus now because of that.
And
Love Octopus Octopus too.
I think the difference between just intelligence and the fact that I think
octopuses are most likely cunts.
Yeah.
They might be smart as fuck,
but it's like crows are smart as fuck.
And I'll shoot one of those bitches right in there.
Dirty Cro head.
It's not just smart.
I need smart and Nice.
That's why I liked dolphins.
They're smart and nice.
That's why like Orcas,
they're smart and nice.
Yeah.
But that's just because dolphins are cute and octopuses are ugly.
But if you put like a hat on a dolphin or octopus in might look cute.
It's possible.
It's just too weird.
They don't even have a skeleton.
They don't sit,
they don't roll over.
If you're so smart,
why don't they do tricks?
Yeah.
That was a Goblin shark that they found.
Um,
there were shrimping.
Yeah.
And they found this,
uh,
this is usually a,
apparently they usually find these in Japan and they're very rare.
They don't find very many of them at all.
It's essentially a dinosaur fish.
It's something that really probably shouldn't exist anymore.
It's one of those things that just hasn't quite died out yet,
but it is old as fuck.
Harriet is so weird looking fish hair.
I don't think of that as heroin.
What are you talking about?
Hanging out with a cat?
It looks like as a bunch of cat hair all over.
I see it.
It's hard to say what that is.
I guess it is a hair.
Is that what it looks like?
It's shrimp have hair.
That's what our lobster of hair.
That's why it freaks me out.
Something.
When I see hair on things,
it's like when is that a hair?
Like what is that stuff?
It's not hair.
I don't know.
Lobsters don't have hair,
dude.
They have some weird sort of a fibrous under
parts.
Yeah.
It's kind of like when you catch a girl on the right sign and you never noticed.
You had like those little whiskers and you're like,
oh,
you know,
it's kind of like that when you eat
the whisker slow you down.
Yes,
man.
It really freaks me out.
Especially then that that peach fuzz sometimes when it's too hefty,
then you,
I can't,
I can see it when it even at night.
But you get that sunny,
see that fuzz all over your face.
Duct tape.
That shit.
Um,
I don't know man.
It just,
it freaks.
I'm like,
oh my gosh,
he's got a beard.
Guys are so picky.
That's why like Asians,
they have zero hair.
You know,
guys are so picky when it comes to women.
Like we'll,
we'll like any little thing.
Yeah.
And chicks will fuck Donald Sterling.
Exactly.
Or we could be the difference right there.
It could be fat,
all kinds of wrong shit going on
one,
you know,
that was the most shocking thing.
It wasn't that an 81 year old dude was racist.
It was,
I wasn't,
you know,
it was talking about that 81 year old dude is
how old is he?
He'll,
he might even not be,
he's at least piano.
You know what I'm saying?
He's doing something weird,
telling it up.
He's doing something weird to her and I just didn't appreciate the way she sat
dignified in the interview with her crazy answers.
I didn't watch that.
Oh,
you got to see me.
You don't have any desire.
I feel you.
I couldn't care less.
The the,
the thing is to me the,
the cultural significance of it is far more than the actual people involved.
Well,
the cultural significance of what's going on now,
I think across the board when it comes to,
uh,
people representing themselves or saying anything is that things are taken in a
way today.
People are taking a task way quicker,
way more,
fewer way easier to transmit information,
way easier for people to know what a person did.
It's at a different level now.
I think it's a like a cultural evolution accelerator.
That's what I think.
I think it's situations like this,
like to anyone who is like an objective person,
race is not important.
What's important is the quality of how the,
the human being interacts with you,
how they interact with other people,
how intelligent they are,
all the things that we judge a person on.
That's what's important.
Race means zero.
So anybody that's still hung up on race being the number one thing,
like he doesn't want her taking pictures with black guys like,
okay,
what are you saying?
I just think that was more jealous than even racist at that point.
But he,
he gave her the green light to fuck those guys.
Did you hear the same time?
I didn't believe him when he said that.
I just,
I just felt like he was just saying,
you know?
Yeah.
But like before you were mature,
you have like,
it's like somebody having a cheat argument with their daughter.
Like,
I don't want you to do this.
Why?
But you don't tell him the real reason why you tell him a nother words.
You escalate it.
Like every time I get into it with a girl,
like they'll,
they'll exaggerate something else to get what they want.
And to me it's like he was exaggerating,
but bottom line was,
I don't even,
I don't,
my friends are calling me and teasing me about seeing the girl that I'm fucking
with black guys who are probably fucking the shit out of.
And that's embarrassing and that's embarrassing to me
and so do it on the low,
but don't do it at my face,
but I don't really want you to do it at all.
Yeah,
he didn't say all those things though.
He didn't,
but that's what I got.
You can fuck them.
I don't believe.
Don't take Instagram pictures.
Think of it.
Think of the rationale of that.
It doesn't make sense.
Well,
it doesn't make sense to be 81 years old and ever get it to fuck a girl was in
our twenties that shit doesn't make any sense.
It's just the fact that that happens.
I believe in it.
He's,
he's a male.
He's a brief on the shelf to you.
Like that's where Brian's hoping to get to look at.
It obviously can happen.
It can happen if there are prostitutes,
they don't.
If a guy comes in,
he's 80 years old,
you got to fuck that guy to listen.
Driveline is the equivalent of a male dime piece.
He's a billionaire.
The,
there's a few of them in the world.
Like if you're,
if you're,
if you're a chick and you can get out of billionaire,
they fee 80 80 doesn't mean nothing.
Why
does that about and that fascinating?
I guess it's just like he bought her a lot of shit.
Yeah.
Bought her a lot of Nice stuff or some shitty,
she would never be able to get probably Bugatti.
Yeah.
Bentley Bentley and two Ferrari's,
the thing it was,
but it's like,
okay,
is that prostitution?
What does that,
how does that work?
Is it totally,
how do you know?
I mean,
maybe she really did love him.
Come on.
Maybe she loved him because he bought her all that stuff.
Is that prostitution,
prostitution?
We,
I don't know if that is man.
I don't know if that is,
you know,
what else is prostitution or it's Pimpin like when a successful family,
right.
Like has a daughter and they tell her they sent her to school educator and tell
her she has to marry a lawyer or somebody successful.
Mm.
That's prostitution.
It is the way,
but it's better that than not educating your daughter about the dangers of
marrying a bitch about the dangers of macro,
like a male bit
campaigns ran.
Right.
So he's like,
you know,
can I just borrow a couple hundred bucks?
Never gets his shit together,
never gets a steady job.
And it's always other people's fall and he's,
you know,
if you'd get a deal lawyer,
most likely he's not going to be that.
At least you figured out his way through law schools.
You've got a degree.
Did the tough stuff to get a doctor,
guys,
a smart guy,
you know,
get a guy who's got a respectful position in this community.
It's like escort streetwalker I'd rather be an escort if I was a chick.
Yeah.
Well it's like girls don't,
we don't require that same shit.
Have you like late.
We don't require women to be anything other than Nice.
Like you would,
you,
would you get bummed out if you were dating a girl and you found out that she,
she was a uh,
uh,
like a,
a greeter at a restaurant?
No,
I'm single.
So that's who I normally date.
Like somebody,
I'm not making a ton of money by any chance,
but most of the women I date,
I make more money than them and it never matters to me.
Right.
So it's going to be a waitress or greed or just,
you know,
so you know,
it's a weird thing man,
where people,
people don't like that.
The changing of the traditional relationships with a woman who makes more money
and the woman has more power than the man has.
When,
when that is unbalanced,
it's uh,
it makes for a weird dynamic.
Some people can pull it off,
but a lot of people can't.
Most people can't.
And they don't want to admit that.
You know,
like I,
I've,
I've seen some people that are pulling it off and I have a friend,
he,
he only works a little bit and his wife works a lot and he's at home with the
kids most of the time,
but they're very happy and it does work.
So you can't say it never works,
but for the most part,
that dude's fall apart and it's usually for the most part,
the woman gets tired of the dude's not making any money.
That happens to be honest,
that it depends which restaurant you're your girls greeter
at.
Cause if it's like Hooters,
it's like,
Oh God,
she's not eating hot enough to be a Hooters waitress.
Maybe she didn't want to be awake.
Maybe she's hot or she's like,
I'm too hot to be walking around carrying drinks.
I need to just be right here
with my weird fucking Tan skinned nylons.
Yoga and nylons,
yoga pants,
yoga pants.
Those things still turned me on now,
like when a girl like a pair,
she stole from work,
you know,
a pitching stuff.
All I think of and just not a negative thing,
but it's a little weird is when I see those,
I think sweaty feet,
those girls have sweaty feet.
They have to work in yoga pants.
Dot.
Not In yoga pants,
but in those Hooters wardrobes.
Girls or got some sweaty feet.
No,
no way.
They don't heal plastic on your feet and you're walking around,
you heat it up.
You know,
we've figured out a long time ago,
you're not supposed to do that.
It's supposed to wear like organic fibers like cotton shit.
Otherwise your feet stink.
They weird out you fucking dummy.
I got athletes,
athletes who his feet.
Yeah,
they should be wearing wool.
Wool is,
it's really good for your feet if you sweat a lot.
This whole Donald Sterling thing that has come to light.
I think one thing I thought of a great idea for a company,
if you want to invest Ya,
oh against you.
I don't want to invest in your comms.
I think it's going to be,
I think it's going to blow up.
It's selling these things that what she's been wearing around,
there's like Tron,
like you're half punk.
It's a daft punk.
Like wow.
Pfizer thing.
And I guess ever since this whole case visor,
companies are saying that there had been song like ridiculous amounts of,
of these visors and it seems like that's going to be the next popular thing.
That's so good,
man.
Visors are a good mood.
Yeah cause it covers your whole face.
Let's start to have to do this right now that's like today we got to call these.
That's not a bad move dude.
Visors.
It's do it.
Have a little logo.
Right.
Wear visors.
Pretending that the is after him.
That would be like the new thing like to fake like you need a visor.
You know like you show up at a girl's house or word advisor.
She's like bitch you don't need a buyer.
Like no you don't.
My last comedy central special just blew the fuck
I need.
You know what's going to happen?
These are going to become popular and then they're going to turn the Google
glass type shit so this is going to be like a full like 17 inch flat screen in
your face.
I'm a dope idea.
That actually is a great idea and they more star wars.
That's great.
Dan idea is fantastic.
Having one of those as a visor,
one of those,
you just see that new thing that there were a,
Samsung was a,
they were showing some new screen that they have that's a flexible screen.
It could roll like a ball parchment and it actually,
uh,
the,
the image goes around the edge like all the way around the side,
like say if it's that fat you see part of the image on that side as well.
All the way up until the top.
They can have that on that.
Totally.
That's exactly what the perfect thing for,
you know,
crash at the float lab.
He devised a special of screen
is pretty fascinating stuff.
The float lab is um,
a sensory deprivation tank place in Venice.
Okay.
The Guy who runs it is this,
the super genius,
crazy dude who's just obsessed with making the very best tanks since I figured
out how to make up a screen that when you know,
you know what a whole float tank is.
The whole thing about sitting in a salt water,
do you know it all?
Do you understand that Michael Jackson had gone?
No,
no,
no.
As I say,
he had a hyperbaric chamber,
hyperbaric chamber,
which is really good for healing.
Like athletes use hyperbaric chamber,
you break a bone or something like that.
Apparently cuts down on the,
the healing time helps heal injuries.
Um,
Uriah faber used one when he was,
he got his leg fucked up and one of his fights,
real bad,
bruising on his leg and he helped heal it up in there.
Um,
but that wasn't it.
What's yours for?
It's a,
it's a sensory deprivation tank.
You float in it and you,
you don't feel the water because it's the same temperature as your body and it's
a thousand pounds of salt in the water.
So you lie down,
you just float like the Dead Sea.
It's amazing.
It's great.
You like,
you trip out in there,
you have these weird imagery,
visual things.
You don't see anything,
you don't hear anything.
So as you get more relaxed when you're in the tank,
you start to have these weird hallucinations,
selfies and occasionally,
um,
but that's,
uh,
why did I bring that up?
Oh,
that's not the sensory deprivation tank.
He,
he came up with this screen that hovers just inches in front of your face and
it's such a low amount of light that's emitted by the screen that you don't see
the actual screen itself.
You just see the image.
So because the tank is so dark,
there's no light in there at all.
You pull the lid shut and it's complete darkness.
You Open your eyes,
you close your eyes,
it looks exactly the same to you.
This screen,
which is hovering in front of you,
you absorb only the image.
So it's like the image is floating in the sky above your face and you can watch
things like documentaries or like,
like a,
like a how to thing like a golf and squash and all or something like that.
Yeah,
and because you're floating,
you're at,
you have way less distractions.
You have way more resources.
Your mind has more resources to apply to learning something.
It's like if you were trying to learn something really intense,
like it was hard,
but some people were arguing right next to it,
you'd have to get the fuck away from them because you wouldn't be able to pay
attention to whatever you're reading.
While the idea is that just your whole body just sitting down,
just your ass touching this chair is all information that you are getting to
deal with in your brain.
You have to constantly manage it.
You're constantly so your resources are spent managing distance and touching
things and you know how your body feels and what you ate today and all that
jazz.
When you were in the tank,
there's nothing.
Nothing.
As long as you go to the bathroom before you go in there,
once you relax and float,
you just floating.
How long are you staying in there for the minimum?
I go in there.
It's usually an hour the most.
I go in there,
it's like two hours.
I've done longer,
but I think two hours is the right amount.
You can get printing.
No,
no,
cause it's salt.
Yeah.
You don't get pruney at all.
Weird.
It's totally different.
I've got to get one of those at the crib,
get one at the crib,
get a crip first.
But as soon as I put this light,
you're floating above your head.
Makes me think that that's exactly what could these things could be like,
like you could just lie back and watch a movie like fuck having a big giant
screen.
You lie back in the movies like Oculus rift style,
like completely enveloping your face.
Yeah.
And you got to get like text notifications on the side and so big would be like
an imax screen and it's lightweight too because you could probably make it
pretty lightweight and just have it on the little band.
Imagine if he did that and they found out that it enhances your vision because
you're constantly looking at these things right in front of you and your,
your vision becomes super powerful.
Or Zoom in on your hand,
like pinch to zoom on your hand and you actually can folk like zoom,
you're on visiting,
like have a camera in the front.
So it's like actually recording like Google glass,
everything and just adding to it.
So then you could zoom in and your own vision.
Well,
if that's going to be the case,
then your interface,
like what you're gonna be able to do,
you're gonna be able to do it like minority report style in the air,
in front of your Lens.
Absolutely.
And because it's your hand like you're,
you'll,
you'll be able to recognize your hand the same way,
like your fingerprints get recognized by an iPhone,
that kind of same shit.
I bet you'll be able to just start
pinching reality in front of you.
And since everyone's going to be having these on all the time,
well one,
the Paparazzi,
he's never going to take your photo by also,
your face is going to be like the next tip because you never see the face
anymore.
So when a girl takes off her offer match and you're like,
oh my God,
I wanna fuck that.
Employees need to stop talking.
Just stop talking today.
I'm not even thinking before you saying shit
covered,
like you know something up.
It's not that,
it's just the way you say it.
It hurts people's brains and always leads to pussy blow jobs going to go up.
It's not,
it's just retarded.
It's ridiculous.
I think it's possible that we could you have a use for that thing though?
Yeah,
that totally makes sense that you would be able to use it as a Jew,
a big giant screen.
Just pull things in front of you.
Like you said,
you could like be looking at something at a distance.
Oh I see.
Fire.
What is that?
Zoom in on it and press Google and it'll fucking get her direct coordination of
where you are and how far away that is and what that is.
They already have range finders.
They have these things that are these laser range finders,
so you get pointed at something and it'll tell you exactly how far it is to the
foot,
which is bananas.
It's crazy.
21 yards.
Like what?
Like you could tell exactly how far that thing is.
So if that's the case,
they're going to be able to incorporate that sort of technology with GPS
technology.
What's going to really realize where you are,
where it picks up your signal.
Realize the range at which you're looking at something,
factor it in,
zoom in on that location.
Oh,
that fire is coming from the city of Blah,
blah blah.
And there they had an explosion of the factory.
You'll be able to watch the Google News Beep,
the oppressive button in front of your face and it'll play you a video.
That's the news of all the things that are happening in front of you.
This makes me one of the,
where the fuck have I been?
Am I in this world?
It's coming,
man is going on.
We've got range finders.
All that.
Oh yeah.
Range finders are important for hunting.
Oh,
okay.
Especially archery when they,
uh,
like you have to figure out where the thing is,
like how far away it is.
Cause you're like a bullet shoot straight as an arrow for like a hundred yards.
But an Arrow has more of a dip to it.
Write an Arrow,
doesn't,
it doesn't have as much power as a gun obviously.
So like you have to calculate how far the Arrow like dips,
right?
Figure out where it's gonna land.
Here's a trick question.
Sounds crazy.
But if you take a gun in one hand and a bullet and the other hand and you pull
the trigger at the same time,
exactly as you drop the bullet,
which one hits the ground first
shot the one from the gun?
It's a trick question.
They hit exactly same time because gravity is the same for both the bullet and
for the bolt that you dropped because the bullet is going to go straight for a
long,
a long time,
but it's going to still drop.
It's still gonna drop.
Whereas the boat that you're holding is going to drop right in front of you.
It's good that you're gonna hold it.
You're going to let it go.
It'll drop right there.
This bull is going to go like seven miles and then drop in the same amount of
time.
That's the difference.
The difference is not the amount of time that it takes.
It's not that amount of time that it takes for the bullet to hit the ground is
exactly the same.
It's just the distance that the bullet that you shoot we'll go will be the
difference.
Isn't that crazy?
Unless you shoot straight up in here,
why are you making a face dummy?
And then there's a calculation if you shoot straight up in the air and it wasn't
me.
That's an issue.
That's cheap.
That was on my face.
You have to be parallel.
He's making it only makes sense.
Yeah.
If,
if it's parallel,
right?
Like you can't spare a little bit.
Exactly.
That is the look of skepticism right there.
Well,
it makes sense if you stop and think about it.
I mean think the graph,
it doesn't defy gravity.
It just defies gravity while it flies straight.
I mean it's just,
it's flying straight.
So there's some defiance of gravity there,
but the amount of time that it flies straight is exactly the same as the amount
of time.
If you just drop a bullet,
this one's got force,
this one does it,
Jamie,
you know there's no microphone on you.
So the bull you're shooting has forced.
Exactly.
It doesn't though.
Yeah.
But it's still,
it's going to drop in the same amount of time as long as it's,
as long as it's going straight.
Yeah.
The only thing I was thinking that there is an explosion so they did it so the
explosion doesn't like,
I don't know,
like it doesn't,
you would think right drop the same time they did it on this show radio lab.
They were explaining it and apparently it's
a trick question.
They're still using radios.
No,
no,
no.
Do Radio lab is awesome.
I think it's probably,
I believe there's probably a website that you can go,
okay let's,
if you drop a bullet,
drop a bullet or shoot a bullet,
which one hits the ground first?
It makes sense if you think about it though,
right?
I see what you're saying but,
but if it's being pushed out,
it seems like the drop wouldn't happen the same time as the bullet drop.
Mythbusters did a thing on it.
Did anyone ever find out if that mythbusters photo of that dude naked,
was that real or fake?
I don't know what you're talking about.
The bald guy.
Crazy.
My stats.
There's like a picture of him like naked that was really popular like five years
ago.
Like true while he's getting fucked in the butt or something.
Well that's not nice.
Um,
come on.
Do you still work on the boondocks seen?
Nah,
I only did the first season.
It's such a good show.
Do you still watch it?
Do you like it?
Uh,
it wasn't odd.
It just started coming back on and,
uh,
I don't have a TV right now.
Yeah.
I'll people to watch it.
Sorry.
No.
What are you going to do about all that?
Have you even thought about it yet?
I'd have to like move back into my house that I just moved out of.
That would be the crazy,
my neighbors would be looking at me like,
what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
It's all your stuff in storage right now.
Some of it will just take a blanket and a pillow in it.
A laptop.
Okay.
The other,
the other factor,
apparently the earth curve of the earth.
It seems that this is what they're saying though.
It seems that they're saying that they land at the same time and it might even
be that the bowl that you drop lands quicker or the,
uh,
the bill that you shoot lands.
Corker.
Did you got Siri?
No ass serious.
See what she says?
Who says just Google it for you.
She won't,
she won't
really answered something like that will fall first.
A gun shot bullet or bullet drop off from hand.
This is what series is gonna say.
Oh my God,
you're retarded.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I found this on the web.
Uh,
it says,
oh,
okay.
If you shoot a bullet fast enough in the horizontal direction,
you can get it to orbit around the earth.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is this.
They will hit the grant the same time he told me
insane the,
yeah,
that's what they're saying.
It would have to be some insane kind of gun.
Well,
you can conceivably shoot something that's so powerful.
You can get a bullet in orbit if you shoot at the horizon.
If you ignore air resistance,
I guess maybe or or defeated just with sheer force an aiming in the right
direction,
but because of the curvature of the earth.
See,
I guess it just makes sense that the bullet would have hit the ground.
Like really is just dropping.
Like that is the whole idea of grabbing the first place that the spin is what's
causing everything to pull.
So the spin
would have to be factored in.
Like when the bullet drops and the earth is spinning because it's been,
we're spinning a thousand miles an hour,
you know,
and it's just weird curvature to things.
The whole idea just freaks me out that were floating,
you know,
just the fact that this planet is just a float in the middle of some space.
Yeah,
it's a freak out.
It's a freak out that you don't like to engage in because it's too,
and we just accepted.
Yeah,
so bananas that you are forced to watch reality shows just to cleanse your
palate of any weirdness.
I guess it be like if you were jumping from like two buildings,
two buildings,
exactly the same.
If you were to just jumps or false straight from one building,
you would fall.
But if you were to jump up cheating even saying because the bullet doesn't go up
to bay view viewers somehow just,
yeah,
you can't do it.
Your mind to
think these things through.
The people who are listening to this is people on the other end and they have a
life that they have a mind of their own and they don't want your,
your thoughts bouncing around inside their fucking head.
They give,
you were jumping from building to building,
you'd be going up like,
yeah,
it'd be like shooting a gun up and exactly.
So yes.
Yes.
That's a good way of describing shooting,
shooting a gun straight.
Still be falling.
It's same way.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Especially with the curvature of the earth.
Apparently that's what it is.
It's going really fast,
really far,
really quickly,
but it still falls to the exact amount of time when those fucking nuts.
When does the bullet that you shoot stuff falling and when it gets to its
distance?
Well it's going straight but it's going super fucking fast and the earth is
curved so apparently it drops like exactly like as if you were dropping the
bullets.
So if you drop the boat or you shot the bullet,
this one's going really far but at the same distance or the same amount of time,
rather they both hit the ground.
It seems like a mind fuck and a half,
but if you've ever shot a bullet,
you realize how quickly it hits the ground.
They hit the ground really quick,
like you should a bullet and then they just,
they're on the ground.
Like things go flying.
I mean,
we don't think about it.
Right.
Because we assume that it just keeps going for a long,
long time.
Probably about an hour or so.
What's,
my bullets aren't usually hitting something,
so
I don't even think about,
you know,
they just fired them off.
You figure that gone.
That thing's probably still flying.
Yeah.
Meanwhile it's not,
I mean,
well it's already on the ground,
like just as quickly as if you drop it.
How about you drop a bullet and the bullet that you fire
into somebody hits the per ground at the same time.
The body of the person who shot it's the ground to St dies of bullet.
You dropped.
No,
I don't think that's related.
That's okay.
Just checking.
That wouldn't be related.
All right.
That's a different experience.
That's a hole.
The gravity itself is a rear real mind fuck.
And the idea that somehow or another it applies to these planets
and it has something to do with mass and has something to do with the spin and
that these things can even be applied to some asteroids.
Some asteroids have gravity,
there's asteroids that are so big,
they have gravity,
and then there's,
there's things that,
there's a whole belt of shit that somehow or another tied together and all
floating around,
and sometimes this causes them to have bands around planets where you just look
out and you can actually see it with a telescope and all that shit is just rocks
spinning around outside of giant gas,
giant bubble planet fucking thing.
Like,
whoa.
The whole idea of planets and solar systems,
it's just too much,
man.
It's too much to wrap your head around that.
Anything that we think is significant,
everything you just said makes me think,
what the fuck are we doing every day?
Oh,
this shit is going took,
oh,
that's paying student loans based to the fighting traffic,
trying to get the new iPhone.
Fuck all this space.
Shit.
I need a bigger screen.
This is Bull Shit,
eh?
Yeah.
Everyone's fighting traffic and meanwhile we're spinning in space.
This this lady was telling me today about the rents and Santa Monica just about
how brutal it is.
Just couldn't get a place in Santa Monica.
She was,
she was driving from work all the way to Hollywood where she can afford a place
that just the idea of being stuck an hour and 45 minutes just trying to get to
your house,
which is less than 10 miles away.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
it's so crazy,
Jesus.
It's insane.
A lot of stuff in La is not that far,
but it does take a monumental amount of time to get there.
The fact that this is all going on while we're in space lead the great beyond.
I mean what it's one of the most ironic things ever is that we're running out of
space while we're flying through infinity and nobody cares.
I mean,
that is what real estate prices going up is you're running out of space,
so the space becomes very valuable.
That's why it's really valuable to have a home on the beach.
There's not much,
it's a very finite amount of space.
You want a house right by the beach?
Listen Buddy,
you've got to paint,
paint,
paint.
You want a front seat to the tsunami?
Yeah,
I got to pay.
It's quite ironic isn't it?
That at the same time we're running out of space while we're flying through
infinity.
That is there is one of the most ironic things about the human race.
That's a clear sign of how crazy we are.
I get it.
There's certain places that have more resources.
There's certain places that have better climates.
I get it.
California is a good place.
People figured it out.
It's a good spot to stop.
Not a lot of rain.
Sunny is shit.
People look good.
They were very little close because it's hot all the time.
It's a good place to get your freak on.
Bam,
I'm staying,
you know,
fuck,
fuck the rent or fuck the commute and that there.
They charge you for it.
Yup.
You gotta pay for it.
Yeah.
It's just so ironic that all this is going on to distract the shit out of us
while were hurling through infinity and we have no idea what this is all about.
I will never beat up a nerd again.
They're important.
They're important,
and they into interesting stuff.
They're going to do the hard work,
man.
You're not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it.
You can do it.
He ain't going to do it.
What the fuck's going to do it without?
Without someone out there doing the hard work.
We're doomed.
Then we're believing in fire guys and sacrifice our paper.
Fucking snakes with feathers.
This lady,
this lady did my astrology chart the other day.
Oh Shit.
They call it these days.
Well here's the crazy,
so
going to get a studio apartment in Hollywood so the lady doesn't do a credit
check.
She does your charts.
That's your credit check.
So then she was telling me my get the fuck out.
I swear to go away.
Given that lady at nickel
price apartment,
I should have taken it in retrospect.
Yeah.
I can't live here too crazy.
So what happened once you did your charts?
The first time I've like,
I've never been to a psychic or no shit like that.
So,
and then she wanted to know my time.
I gave him a date of birth,
but she wanted to know the time.
I was like,
I don't know the time when I was born.
So I kind of,
she just kind of dessert.
There's maybe three types of times and she just gave me one and there was some
things she would start talking about.
Your Jupiter is lined up with your anus.
This is a good time.
And it sounds funny,
but that's exactly what she said.
But then she was,
there was some things she was kind of accurate about,
says you had a,
you got a job and so on and so that paid decent amount of money,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
So I was like,
oh,
okay.
She's,
she was in the,
it wasn't far off.
Yeah,
but that's,
they just ask you questions and they,
they start fucking figuring your personality out and then they plot and think
about,
oh,
this card means this is the joker.
And so you might be a comedian.
Come on man.
I mean it's all nonsense.
All of it's nonsense.
She could've googled.
There's something,
there is nothing about science,
right,
right
to astrology.
Don't get me wrong,
nobody get me wrong.
I think there is something to it.
I think they'd been doing it for a long,
long,
long fucking time for a reason and I think that there's probably some sort of an
effect that the gravity of other planets and the way the lines has on a person,
some sort of an effect.
I don't know how much of it is real though.
The idea that they could tell your future.
That's the thing that was blowing my mind that she could say she could chart
chart me as an individual.
I was like,
I don't know if it's a feeling like I don't think I'm that important enough
where you could like put my date and the time and then check when the moon hits
wouldn't even,
the problem
I'm having with it,
the big problem is she doesn't even know when you were born.
That was the post to me.
Yeah,
but that's supposed to make a big difference is the most,
the time in which you're born.
And I do all of it.
I didn't care enough to like go get it for like,
I could ask my mother,
but I,
you know,
I was skeptical but she was,
yeah,
she is.
She had a few things.
Right.
I don't know how much of it was assessed experience of good guessing or you
know,
most of it's that dude you ever taught here.
Pendula talk about that,
how they do those things.
No,
he's pretty enlightening when it comes to a all sorts of scams and confidence
games and how they can make,
get you to believe that you know that you're a not revealing anything,
but they're leading you in certain ways.
And for the average person,
they're pretty effective.
There's a bunch of effective techniques where they,
I see your,
there's a woman in your past.
There's a,
my grandmother is she,
I'm not sure how old she was.
My Mom,
my grandmother died when she was 50 yes.
And there's something,
something she didn't get to do.
Well,
she always wanted to be a dancer.
This is amazing.
They just fucking,
they just started doing and leading you and you talk along with them.
And I'm,
I'm,
I cannot help me out.
There's an Ar,
is there an are somewhere?
Oh my God,
her name was Regina.
That's amazing.
They start doing shit like that and it's just,
people find a reason for that are,
um,
do you Virginia Yell?
Yes.
That's it.
Five years.
And for that they find a place for it.
They just look for a place for it.
You know what that's like?
That's like a,
so there was this detective,
he quit the force,
but he realized he put this chicken jail based on interrogating her years ago.
Like when he went back and listened to the tapes,
like there was a,
I think it was a robbery and a,
or maybe a murder,
but he interviewed her and interrogated her for a long time.
And then she kind of confessed to it at the end,
but she admitted some stuff or gave them evidence along the lines.
Like they were like,
you had Chinese food.
Right?
And she's like,
yeah,
Chinese food.
And then she told him he but he didn't know or realize that he showed her the
receipt.
So when she mentioned eaten orange chicken or whatever it was on the receipt,
he thought,
okay,
I got her,
she is involved in this like,
and there was just a lot of stuff where over the course of hours of
interrogation the cop gives you a lot of stuff and it becomes your fact and you
start saying it back and then you think you got her but you gave them all this
info.
I'll go you one crazy [inaudible].
They actually use that in India to convict a woman of murder based on the
results of a brain scan.
What?
Yup.
It's called Fmr.
I and F MRI is a functional magnetic imagery,
whatever it Mris.
But the idea is that they can detect certain aspects of your mind or certain
aspects of your thinking and one of them is knowledge of a subject.
So say if they showed you a photo of the crime scene and then you reacted in a
certain way that certain way would indicate knowledge of a crime scene.
But here's the problem.
We don't know if that knowledge of the crime scene was put into your head during
the interrogation,
right?
Just putting your head during the,
um,
the media discussing,
finding out,
like if you're being charged with murder,
let's say murder.
You're going to fucking read everything.
Like,
Holy Shit.
If you're innocent,
let's,
let's pretend.
I mean,
for the sake of let's,
this is a totally new scenario,
is,
gentleman,
forget about this case in India.
I have no attachment to it.
I don't know the actual s whether it's someone was guilty or not guilty.
I don't know.
I just know that Fmr,
I was used to come up with a conviction.
If you were not guilty,
but they thought you were,
they're going to talk to you for a long fuck,
and you're going to be like,
what is this place like it happened in the kitchen.
What fucking kitchen?
They'll show you a picture.
Have you ever seen this kitchen?
You're like,
I have fucking never seen that kitchen.
And then later they give you the FM Ri and they ask you about the kitchen.
Oh,
he has knowledge of the kitchen.
It is possible that,
so this is not an exact science.
It is possible that you can somehow under the give someone a memory and they can
accept it as their own.
You can actually read it on a,
on a machine.
And that's what happens in law.
Whether they use the,
the,
the what's,
what's the name of the machine?
F Mrr.
Fmr.
I'm just shocked that India even has that technology like this,
the place that has water,
doesn't have water running water in most places will,
it has a lot of fucking people,
man,
fucking people in India and they're wasting time on a convicting somebody with
like a mind scan and he has a lot of high level technology to man.
Why do you think when you make tech calls
in India,
you know,
there's a lot of people over there.
It's just,
it's a completely different sort of an environment and having a billion people
and your planet and they have,
yeah,
yeah.
I've got to defend themselves against Pakistan.
They do both at that beef.
They hate each other and they're right there looking at each other.
Tada.
Waiting for one old dude.
They're going out.
I think that's fucked up that day.
So she,
she's in jail or whatever their version of prisoners
allegedly.
I mean,
who knows?
she might've been a murderer.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
I just know that the idea of being able to read functional memory,
my,
I'm completely ignorant about the science behind it.
So when I talk to people that were scientists,
they said it's very dangerous.
It's very dangerous.
Not It's minority report.
Ish.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
it's not ready.
It was like,
this is not indicative.
It's like one thing.
If say,
if I could read your mind and you could say,
uh,
Ian,
we show me your bathroom please,
and you could show me the image of your bathroom.
I can actually see it.
I go,
okay.
It till it's like quantified like that,
right.
You looking at someone's brain,
they functional knowledge of a bathroom is a fucking murderer.
Oh yeah,
I,
we got him.
Yeah.
Like that's the new swearing on a Bible.
And,
and as,
as,
as swearing on the Bible isn't shaking off.
Exactly.
Let's make this thing shaking.
So let's use a brain scan.
That's so true with no,
no,
no factual basis for it.
Well,
memories,
real weird,
man.
They,
they've been able to introduce memories in mice now.
They've been able to introduce artificial memories.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In humans for hundreds of years probably,
right?
Yeah.
Most of the girls on Sheree and candidate type shit.
Most of the girls updated try to artificial memory.
Yes sir.
Oh,
those are hilarious.
It's called lying.
It's called lying and pimp game.
Yeah.
Sometimes people will fucking put things in your head and you're pretty sure
they're right.
Yeah.
Like,
I don't know.
I know,
I don't remember anything.
Like,
sometimes people say,
I remember the time we did this at me,
you and so and so,
and I said,
Oh shit.
Like we like,
that's happening so much to me now.
Like I know my memory is unreliable.
That's what the point I'm at.
That's hilarious.
I know mine,
everybody's memories.
Unreliable people,
they morph their memories to make them more convenient for their knowledge of
the past.
Whether it's as them as a victim or as them as the winner or as them as the,
the,
you know,
oh I didn't get my fair shake.
You know,
there was some behind the scenes shenanigans.
Meanwhile know it's,
you are fucking,
yeah,
yeah.
Regular memory.
Reliable.
But they're going to use this machine.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're not ready yet.
But one day they will,
one day we'll be able to access each other's brains.
Just like you,
we send each other photos.
Like if you were somewhere cool and you sent me a photo and get it on my phone,
we're getting,
you're to be able to see my,
my,
I'm going to be able to,
you know,
put public.
So all I want to make my,
on my eyesight public,
cause I'm at Yellowstone,
you know,
and you'd go public with your,
your vision and you show everybody else.
And he can put it up on a database where people draw from.
That'll be like the first step.
People will share their experiences.
A few people sneak in porn or them jerking off,
but for the most part
people are going to share experiences and then it'll just go to a,
Hey,
I'm Carl.
I'm always on.
This is a bit depends.
Motherfuckers always on 24,
seven,
you can watch him shit.
You can watch them jerk off,
you can watch them at Sachs and people just start,
they only live their life.
Can't wait to get home and be Carl is it came with the cross out there.
Just doing ecstasy and bag and pitches driving the fast lane.
It's a fun animal.
If Carl's channel became public,
everybody would want to just be in.
Yeah,
you can be the hottest selling.
Uh,
yeah.
And people would start complaining.
They would say,
look man,
nobody is living a real life anymore.
Everybody's living other people's lives.
He has a game.
Came up with a great concept.
Yeah,
because your life is boring as fuck.
But you could just be a Carl.
Carl is out there.
Baldwin and it gets Carl gets shot.
Boom.
You're used to go back to regular life.
That's the risk because then you'd have to find a new channel to subscribe to.
All right.
You know Carl's dead Eddie TV
shows that.
Yeah,
exactly.
Let's follow Eddie calls,
best friend.
That will be a new art form,
the new art form.
We'll be living your life in a spectacular manner to which some people would
want to actually give up being a real person so they can be you and experience
it directly and you will become a million people they see through you.
We're not exactly sure whether or not they influence Carl.
We think that Carl is acting independently,
but it is possible if you think about it that all those minds linked up together
could form one unique and universal direction in which crawl might want to go.
Well,
that's kind of like Instagram right now.
That's bananas,
but you're talking about taking it to the next level son,
because if call realizes that he gets a lot of views what he's doing,
he's going great summers,
then he's going to do more threesomes course if he gets a lot of views when he
realizes that he's on a plane or in a Jacuzzi or just
that look,
when a guy gets recognized for being a big fat guy and like gets famous for
being a fat guy.
If you ever seen one of those guys,
talked to their agents and the agents will tell you,
I've seen it happen with my own eyes.
Don't lose weight,
man.
If you lose weight,
you're gonna lose roles.
Right.
Why is that?
Because,
because they've locked on to the idea of you as the factor.
Gotcha.
Right.
They just decide,
okay.
They decide.
We still,
it's just of we just keep this going.
Don't fuck this up if you will.
In the literal bravery training,
they just keep eating so they'll stay fat and funny.
If you told the fat guy like,
hey dude,
people love eating and if you just,
I just need you to just go fucking crazy.
If you just eat a lot bro,
all day,
people are gonna just be you.
It's a lot of fat people.
There's skinny in real life,
but they could live like a fat guy through you and we can make money.
I'm Skechers is it on this?
Yesterday they wants to sponsor eating show.
I mean it gets some guy who just all day he does,
he drinks fucking vodka and he eats subs.
Just meatball subs.
Chicken parm all day so people subscribe just so they can experience what it's
like to be fucked up drunk with a chicken like a chicken Parmesan Sob.
Great meatballs and sausage and pepper shit and not allowed to eat anymore.
Drop outs.
Drunk life,
follow that.
And every now and then Carl go to a massage parlor and get jerked off and like,
yeah,
but you can't tell your wife about that.
Like Carl was doing some crazy shit.
What's he doing here?
Like three sandwiches.
Yeah.
You beat Carl and you don't even tell everybody about Carl getting jerked off.
He's eating a sub while he's getting jerked off.
The kid's a maniac.
That's,
that's the next level shit,
man.
That's what's going to happen.
People are saying the kids are wasting their lives.
Right.
You're just wasting life sitting there watching TV,
not even be out there doing anything.
That's just TV.
TV,
TV is like the smoke signals of entertainment.
I mean,
it's beautiful
for us,
but so was a smoke signal when you didn't know where the fuck the camp was.
Where is everybody?
They used to all those it fucker.
I can find them.
That is a lifesaver,
especially when it's cold out.
That shit was a life saver.
That's the TV is,
is this smoke signals of digital entertainment.
One day you're going to actually be that.
You're going to be in that guy's head.
Sorry.
It's starting already slowly with reality shows and all that stuff,
but we're all going to be one.
Everybody got Facebook,
everybody got an Instagram.
Everybody's on something.
That's weird.
You can,
you can,
you know,
you just can't stream it the way you're talking about,
but you know that's coming.
That's going to happen.
It's going to be weird as fuck and it's going to first take place through
something like a Google glass or something like that.
Visor adviser,
the Google visor.
Jump on advisor idea.
So real we need to do,
let's do it.
Come on,
let's get in the fires of game with.
I'm not interested.
I have,
I have my time section doubter,
right.
No time for anything else.
My time.
There was no way that would make me more happy.
It's just not going to make me more happy.
We can be the Steve jobs and Pfizer's good luck with all that.
Dude.
I'm content.
I'm 100% content.
I have no desire to take on any additional projects if anyone wants to.
Pfizer's,
do you know how difficult that shit would be to do?
Well you need to do is contact Google.
No,
I wanted to start off with just a regular advisor.
I think that's what you have to do.
You have to like first get your feet into being the best Pfizer,
you know,
having the Nike Shoe,
that would be easy dude.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
It's an easy investment right now that can turn into like for me to agree with
you.
It's like how much is this Pfizer?
If you look at that visor,
it's just a piece of plastic,
you know?
It's like,
like all you need to really pay for it.
Like the thing on the top,
like the head piece.
So it's like one of those Vegas visors that hunter s Thompson used to wear,
but it's just bigger.
Yeah.
And it's down on your face.
Yeah,
I could totally see it happen.
I man,
the Chickson innovator,
daft punk,
Marsha,
which she should do is take,
she should start this.
You should start this with her.
I was,
you should do,
should find her.
She's probably still got some of his money squirreled away somewhere.
I can't find him a fucking hole in the park.
The brown bag dug two feet under a tree.
Yeah,
she's got,
she didn't,
she didn't blow all over.
She's,
she's hiding some of it from his wife.
You know that when you're 81 years old,
if you're fucking a guy that's 81 the shit could end at any moment.
They know it,
they know it,
they plan for the future.
I doubt she didn't have like an ATM card or something.
I mean it just doesn't make any sense to me.
I,
she claims she has a job,
she's like his personal assistant or something high.
A better,
a better title.
The title don't be impede on.
That's what she has.
I bet she doesn't have that job anymore.
And I know she in it and the interview is banana.
She says she just like Barb was say you just came from seeing Donald Sterling.
How is he?
And she was talking like,
well Donald's this and that was,
oh he's like a father figure to me and you know,
I'm just trying to help him right now.
So I was like,
this would be this so bizarre
that if it's true it is still in contact and kicking it like this.
No other way.
In 81 year old guy gets to bang 20 year olds.
They have to be crazy.
That's the only way it works.
And you have to deal with everything.
You're 81 years old,
you have to buy or Bentley and you have to deal with a hundred percent crazy
coming at you on a train all day long drama.
That's not real drama.
This black guys on Instagram,
you've got to deal with all that.
It all comes with this crazy bitch.
You got to just deal with it.
And so part of the game,
it's a part of the game.
You got to accept it.
You got to accept it in her defense.
What I heard and I need to stop doing that,
but I'm going to do it till we Google it,
is that she was part of her job was to record everything that he knew there was
being recorded.
Uh,
it's,
he's,
he's recording it.
Yes.
Is He's,
because it's first when I heard the tape and said,
how did this bitch like she should like work for bits spokesperson for the who
she recorded this with.
Well she finally,
she did.
Yeah,
she recorded it for him and it says,
and then she just took his tape
or he,
she didn't give it to them.
Right.
She might've had it and didn't give it to them.
But here's the deal.
Palm,
if that's the truth,
then that makes it no longer crime.
Right.
Because it's only a crime in California.
If w two people,
uh,
record something and one of them doesn't know about it.
Right.
But as long as both of them know about it in California,
it's not a crime.
Yeah,
no,
I heard it was,
it's his shit and I didn't,
I don't know if she's taping it for him,
but it makes kind of sense and I want it to make sense before we've looked at
it.
And then she palmed it.
So she's not as,
as she is devious as far as pushing him.
Well,
the questions,
but
you know,
the whole story,
it's almost like she got pushed into it because you know the whole story,
she's getting sued
by the wife.
Yeah.
So she's,
this was a self defense move.
Yeah,
for sure.
Because like the wife is trying to get all the money back.
Like she bought,
she bought,
he bought her a condo and a bunch of other shit.
Look at us,
we're like a little TMZ bitches.
No,
no,
but there's a,
there's a social science thing to it and my thing is like there's a bunch of
people here who won't,
will not accept the rules of the game.
The wife is trying to sue like listen wife,
you made it to 80 or whatever with this dude and he's a billionaire.
There's no way that a younger chick in the way nature works.
It's not going to get at your man or your man's going to get,
so for you to sue one of his younger chicks,
that's against,
that's against the laws of the game.
For him not accepting that this young chick with fuck younger dudes,
he's in denial himself and then she,
she's just crazy.
Well she's the type of girl that's willing to fucking 80 year old billionaire
six which again,
you don't,
you know either that you go to another country,
right.
And then you can't trust if you're a 80 minute 80 year old billionaire,
you can't trust a girl who's willing to fuck you with tapes.
Exactly.
So then it's like a lot of like,
it's like three people fucking up.
You know what I thought was the most bizarre about all of it?
Um,
apparently I was correct and that what she is as far as the most recent story is
that she was supposed to record his saying his conversations because he would
say things and then forgot he sat him.
Right.
So He's,
he's got,
he's dementia 81 years old.
He's old as fuck.
So he would say crazy things and then she would record them and you know,
and let him know like what he said.
Well in this case,
somehow or another,
it got leaked how it got leaked to speculation,
but he knew he was being recorded.
All right.
That is true.
So you can't,
it's against the law.
The record,
anyone,
like what if they don't say anything and it's just bathroom noises and stuff.
It's against the law still.
Even if they don't talk in it.
Absolutely.
In California.
If they don't know about it,
it's against the law.
You're not allowed to record.
The default essence can be like if you just put a tape recorder down behind the
toilet,
they don't say a word.
They just did it and then they leave.
That's still against the law even though they don't say it.
It said they're just their spirit being in the room,
the noises of them,
um,
being recorded.
There are actual physical presence being marked by the sound of their feet.
I think that's probably illegal.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why they used to tape criminal
guilty as fuck.
He's like,
if you take a tape and put it behind the back in burp boilers in Burbank,
whatever,
and the girl might happen to be a stripper,
whatever.
That's that combination.
That's never gonna happen.
But if it did,
it's just they know that you were recording her pooping.
It's just interesting because I guess recording.
No,
no,
Brian,
that's an interesting fucking space is interesting.
We you talking about that you clam up and you're like,
oh
no,
I thought it was crazy.
The whole thing is that he got a two point $5 million fine.
That was a Max,
like that's a weird thing man.
A fine like a two point $5 million fine.
Like I could see saying like,
all right,
this guy's a piece of shit.
He shouldn't.
Uh,
he shouldn't be able to own a team in our league just because he's such weak
moral moral character.
Let's get rid of him.
The guy's a dick head.
Let's get rid of them.
But to say you're going to,
you're going to find him for being racist since when has to be racist,
like finable.
Well that's crazy.
There's an NBA constitution and under the constitution that's the most you could
find somebody,
and I don't want to put it,
I guess saying something detrimental against the entire league.
So what he said is under that,
so it's a to 52.5 was the Max.
So that's like the top that they're allowed to find anything hurting.
The NBA can be that they can find them for
doing anything.
He's just one team,
but he's hurting the image of the whole.
Right.
I get all that.
I just don't get how they think that they can find someone's getting all the
other owners nervous.
Sound so crazy to find someone from being racist
that the amount that they agreed on to like the entire NBA,
all the owners,
they probably agreed to the amount and it just an amount that won't affect any
of them.
Yeah,
I bet you're right.
That's the maximum of 2.5 million.
Everyone's good.
It's like we spent 2.5 just to get to this meeting.
Don't make 2.5 in a week.
Yeah,
just off the interest of all that money.
Yeah.
That's for folks who don't even know what that means.
If you have $1 billion,
he had a thousand million and a thousand million dollars constantly raining in
percentages.
If you just have some simple mutual funds that generate,
you know,
x amount of percent per month or x amount of percent off of your savings
account.
I mean what is that?
If you have a savings account and you've got $1 billion in it,
I mean how much money do you get?
I mean,
I know most of them don't have liquid assets like that that keep your money in a
bunch of different things.
They have some liquid,
some real estate.
They diversify and stocks and bonds and all that other shit,
but just the sheer numbers that that money is generating if you're doing it
right.
Right.
Should it be staggering?
They should get 1 million bucks a month is nothing comes in.
I'm shocked that he's just still a billionaire.
Yeah.
One,
he's got 1.9 1.9
that's all in 80 years.
What the fuck has he been doing?
How many bitches has he been giving money to
buy Bentley's and shit?
It's a ridiculous that the wife can sue.
Yeah.
I don't think that that suit is going to stand up.
It shouldn't.
It doesn't matter.
She has to defend it.
Hold on.
Yeah,
she has to defend it.
Yeah.
You know,
it's one thing if you,
you sued or divorce,
you know,
you can't,
like,
you can't have a 20 year old bitch on the side and give her fucking Ferrari's.
Get out of my mind.
I've done it to you.
Fuck it.
I'm stilling.
That makes sense.
But to see,
to sue the girl because your husband gave her gifts
and your husband is standing right next to you.
How are you going to skip over him and go to this chair chick?
That is one of the,
just one of the many reasons why marriage is preposterous.
Pastor says so ridiculous.
The idea is so stupid that you get linked to someone financially.
You lock it in place and if that person gives someone some shit and you don't
like it,
that came from my money.
Right?
Didn't he spent it,
but he can't spend money on whatever the fuck he wants to spend it on.
If he bought them,
you know,
if he bought a house just off some person who just bought a house,
would you say you fucking buy that house?
You can't stop the dude from buying a house.
You know,
you might win in court and get half of his money,
but you can't change what he bought.
You can't.
He bought it.
He bought her a fucking car.
He bought her a house.
That's,
that's gone.
That's just like,
feel.
Yeah,
that's,
it's gone.
It's just like buying it from someone and,
uh,
you know,
and,
and keeping it for yourself,
it's gone.
Him and his wife have a really,
really interesting relationship just based on what I've seen.
Like,
uh,
she won one statement,
I don't know the audit statement.
One statement is like,
she does not condone him.
And he's,
um,
his,
his strange wife.
We're not to get with them within days of that,
she's seen with him defending him.
They went,
came out of a restaurant together and she's like,
he's not racist.
And then,
then I saw something today where she's glad that they took the team from him.
What?
So,
so she's gone back and forth.
She's going back and forth and she's obviously in his life or acting or getting,
maybe she's just,
maybe she's just getting paid and maybe she just wants a team to land in a lap
or keeping an eye.
But it's,
it could be.
Yeah.
You never fucking know.
You know,
especially a 80 year old dude who doesn't remember shit.
Right.
And he's got to get a recording every time he talks,
you know,
annoying.
That must be for the wife.
Yeah.
She's like,
look,
you stupid motherfucker.
This is the week we go to Hawaii.
Get your shit together,
let's go.
You know she's probably tired of him.
He's probably tired of all is not.
And then,
oh he's a sweetie.
He's not racist.
You leave,
leave my,
my,
my but alone Donald.
This is just for that is,
yeah,
he the poor bastard.
He's just an old senile,
old racist.
Shitheads
yeah.
And a lot of that shit is like I said,
dementia and it's anonymous anomaly.
It's like
the only thing,
like when everybody wanted him to get fired,
like when it first tapes,
so it's cat.
He came out,
I wasn't down with that cause I wasn't as offended by the tapes because it's
like what a shocker that an 80 year old guy was racist.
But when,
uh,
Adam silver is that the NBA Commissioner gave the speech,
like I was on board with the speech.
I went from not caring whether they fired on or not,
but when Adam silver gave the speech and said band full life,
it was not just the words but the way he delivered it that made me believe in
this guy as a commissioner and that he wanted to fix some shit and that he was
doing it.
He was just doing it for the,
just for the good of humanity and that kind of,
that kind of made me say,
okay,
kick him out.
But before I didn't care.
Right.
I if you,
I don't know if you've seen the speech,
but I felt something,
I just felt something,
I was like some honesty and integrity there.
Well that's important man.
Look,
I mean especially important.
If you look,
imagine if you were the guy who was running the NBA and you weren't a racist and
you got this racist old dickhead that owns the clippers and he says some stupid
shit and they're like,
you dumb mother fucker.
Do you not understand that 80% of his league is black and you say stupid shit
like that.
Like this is the whole reason why basketball is popular is because the athletes
are so fucking good.
Do you understand that 80% of these athletes are Wa are black?
So I mean,
just look at the numbers.
You stupid fuck like you're ruining everything and then being a new,
a good human,
just being a good human being.
Do you want your business to be associated?
Imagine if you,
whatever,
you ran a a chain of comedy clubs,
you know,
and you found out that someone in your chain of comedy clubs,
someone who owns one of your chains was a racist or saying racist shit.
He'd be like,
Oh fuck outta here.
Get outta here out done.
I don't want this guy associated with me.
You'd boot him out immediately.
You'd have to feel like that if you were a person of integrity and you are
running something like the NBA.
But it was,
it was just like,
like when,
so,
so Donald Sterling makes these tapes that I can accept as like not surprised and
because that's what I expect.
That's what I mean.
That's what I expect.
But when another rich guy,
right.
Makes the speech that he makes and with the feeling that he makes.
That's what I don't expect.
Like the honesty and the genuineness that I felt.
I didn't expect that.
Well Shit,
I want to watch it now because of I've only a,
I heard them making fun of it on an opiate and,
okay,
that's totally fair.
So bad.
They were crushing it.
They were,
they said that he looked like Nosferatu and it looked like he should have risen
behind the podium,
like popping out of a coffin.
So stupid.
What is this?
What is his name again?
I think it's Adam
silver NBA president mission Donald Sterling.
I keep just seemed upset.
Like he really took this personally.
It would have been,
um,
it would have been fascinating if they didn't react.
It'd been fascinating.
Like what kind of a blow back that would be.
I think it would be pretty substantial.
It would have been,
it would appeal to it a very substantial,
if they didn't do something about it,
it's crazy.
It was like the clippers are like heroes now.
Everywhere they shell.
Everybody goes bananas.
The clip is a so corny.
They did this,
uh,
this protesting before one of the games where they all walked in the middle of
court.
What a sh things inside out and then dropped the things on the floor and then
they walked away as if they just changed civil rights and like get the fuck
outta here.
Do Shit.
What the fuck is that?
Like will be famous though for it.
If you stop and think about it like this is a civil rights is a biggest civil
rights issues ever has existed recently in modern sports.
Yeah.
What does it but besides Jimmy,
the Greek Jimmy,
the Greek I think got railroaded.
He said some facts.
It's
just the fact that were very uncomfortable for people who are uncomfortable with
people.
I had still to this day don't get it.
Like what did he say?
I used to breed,
likes to eat in slave.
He didn't say he did it.
He said back then they bred a big black books
this past Saturday morning of a conversation that it led to leak included
clippers owner,
Donald Sterling.
The NBA commenced an investigation which among other things included in
interview of Mr Sterling that investigation is now complete
the central findings of the investigation or that the man whose voice is heard
on the recording and on a second recording from the same from the same
conversation that was released on Sunday is Mr Sterling and at the hateful
opinions voiced by that man are those of Mr Sterling.
The views expressed by Mr Sterling are deeply offensive and harmful
that they came from.
An NBA owner only heightens the damage and my personal outrage
setup.
Sentiments of this kind are contrary to the principles of inclusion and respect
that formed the foundation of our diverse multicultural and multiethnic league.
I am personally as guy drawing the piss out of me.
The views expressed by Mr Sterling came from within an institution that I said
that has historically taken,
he's nervous,
such a leadership role in matters of race relations because current and former
players,
coaches,
fans and partners of the NBA took question.
They're very association with the league freshman that are to them and pioneers
of the game like Earl Lloyd show whose birth,
this is where they're mocking Sweetwater Clifton.
Oh,
sweet water.
The Great Bill Russell and particularly Magic Johnson.
I apologize.
I guess they were in the photos.
Is that what that was about?
Those guys?
I think so.
Accordingly.
Yeah.
I think immediately,
I think Bill Russell was too.
I am banning Mr Sterling for life from any association with the Clippers
Organization or the NBA.
Mr Sterling may not attend any NBA games or practices.
Okay.
He may not be present at any clippers facility and he may not participate in any
business or player personnel decisions involving
the team.
He will also be barred from attending NBA Board of governors meetings or
participating in any other league activity.
I like it.
I would like to,
he did it.
You know why I liked it?
He did it because fuck old dick heads like that.
Just,
just fuck a dude who thinks like that.
Right?
Who Cares?
Get rid of them.
Yeah.
It's not like he's hurting anyone out in the street.
You just saying your league doesn't tolerate racism and even by financially
penalizing him 2.5 million,
which is a pittance to a wealthy man like that,
right?
That fucking team is going to be worth an ass load of money and they're going to
sell it.
And guess who makes the money?
Donald fucking sterling.
So by this whole controversy,
his team's probably way more valuable and he's selling the team at the peak.
This is the best his team has ever been.
Oprah.
The only way she's not buying it.
No,
the only,
no.
The only way that it's not going to work is if people get together and decide,
you know what?
Fuck this dude.
Nobody by the clippers making me get rid of it for make them,
make them sell it to the lowest bidder and you know,
make sure that nobody bids more than a hundred dollars for the fuck out.
Just make sure that he gets it for the highest bidder,
but that I people like make an agreement,
I can own it then that I don't know how to play is going to get paid after that.
You're gonna have to figure out a way.
My,
I'm retarded idea has got a lot of holes in there.
It's a lot of holes in it,
but if you could mean if you really want it to come up with people really wanted
to collude and come up with one is is that illegal?
What happens if we do that?
That shit is hell.
Yeah.
He can't collude.
That's like anti iPractice right,
or anti fair anti something,
something.
Yeah,
there's probably some collusion penalties that you would incur,
but if you get people,
all the rich dudes with money so you know we're not buying a clip or this guy's
not going to get any money from us,
then the players are,
fuck
you know what the only problem with that is it's like property.
It's like if somebody buys a house next to you for $50 then the value of your
shit goes down.
I said it ended up being true and the other NBA owners are going to be like,
ah,
and they're powerful enough to sell it to a charity and then rich guy buys it
from the charity.
If someone says like the NBA,
uh,
says like they want $500 million for the Lakers and like a $500 million,
you know the clippers sold for 100 bucks.
Right?
You guys are going crazy.
We don't mind you making a little money,
but this is disrespectful and treating me like I'm an idiot.
You don't think I read the paper?
Oh,
there was special circumstances.
No special circumstances,
Bro.
If she goes down to yeah,
you don't,
they will give you a million about a million,
but one last one.
We're giving it.
We're giving them away.
It's tough to get $1 million since page.
This is not,
you know,
we have the fucking expenses.
We've got to pay the trainer and it's fucking basketball court needs wax.
It's a lot of money involved and own Goddamn team show.
Like we're just going to be making money hand over fist.
They had fucked the whole thing up,
man.
This is what Jimmy,
the Greek said.
He said black people are Betty or athletes.
He said black people are better athletes.
Um,
I don't know.
I think he's right.
Is that right?
He's,
he's at least 80% right?
Yeah.
This is what he said.
This is the quote.
The quote is a little,
you know,
it's a little sketch with,
we're talking about 1988 too by the way.
Right.
Jimmy?
The Greek wouldn't last five minutes today.
He would,
they would catch them on cell phone sites.
Rages,
Shit that,
you know,
a couple of whiskeys in them eating a Hoagie.
It says the black is a better athlete to begin with because he's been bred to be
that way.
Can we just stop there at the,
that's one of the black,
the book,
the black is a problem of black cause I like where he's going,
but the black,
yeah.
You imagine if some like Louis Farrakhan Guy,
the white,
the white list for frying too.
People,
the white believes he is of a high breed because he was not bred to be,
uh,
because of the high thighs and big thighs that goes up into his back and they
could jump higher and run faster because of their bigger thighs.
And he's bred to be the better athlete because this goes back all the way to the
civil war.
When during the slave trade,
the slave owner would breed the big black to his big woman so that he could have
a big black kid.
Sort of facts are there,
but
pretty much white legislation thing was to collation.
Articulation is a,
a little on the crude side.
On the cruise side.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So apparently he was on the network,
um,
talking about,
uh,
you know,
given the inside scoop on gambling.
That's what he used to do.
And he did it for 12 years and he said that,
and that's,
that's,
that's where they ended it for him.
It was CBS fired him and no,
I don't think anybody ever hired him after that.
Uh,
it was,
it was tough.
He went down.
Yeah.
And did he die?
Yeah,
he eventually died,
but he died like broken.
Like he couldn't associate with people that he used to talk to every day and
everything that he loved the sport,
you know,
it's taken from him.
He died it way back in [inaudible] 96 [inaudible] 77 years of age.
That's fucking crazy.
It's amazing how,
one thing too,
man.
One thing,
just if you say something like that,
you can say some stupid shit,
but if you say something that people think is a racist politics thing and you
get stuck.
What Paula Dean Paula Deen.
Yeah.
Well sort of.
Everything's gone for her.
Not really.
She's still doing fucking tours and selling books and that doesn't seem to
affect her as much.
She's got some tour that they were just making fun of on some
a website May.
She'd lost like over a hundred sponsors.
So it did change in her restaurant,
I think is closed now.
Oh,
she had a restaurant.
Yeah.
That's where all this,
how are you sure that it's closed?
Find out we'll,
but we'll Google the repercussions
suffered by Paula Dean.
Um,
I wonder if it's different today too because you could go on like a website and
you could sort of like apologize or argue your position or tell say,
you know,
like did you see that Jeremy Clarkson thing pull up that um,
Brian abandoned that for a moment and pull up uh,
Jeremy Clarkson find for using the n word
or in trouble for using the n word.
That's the guy in England.
Yeah.
Meaning mine.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was stupid.
Oh,
he's an idiot.
These guys have done this before.
I mean I think he's a hilarious guy
sometimes,
but they've said some really racist shit.
Pull it up.
I'm sure he got on TV and apologize.
He made a or on Youtube and he apologized for it.
Jeremy Clarkson is one of the PVC is best known and well paid anchors.
He fronts top gear,
which is a popular car program,
which last year became the most widely watched factual TV show in the world here
in the UK.
Clarks and is known for is edgy humor,
but this time he may have gone too far.
Video of Clark's and apparently using racist language has been linked to the
British media.
In this snippet,
you can hear him mumble the n word Elian
to Lindy skills.
That's him go eeny meeny,
miny moe.
The clip was film several years ago and it was never broadcast and Clark denied
using the term at all,
but after the video was posted online,
he apologized and asked for forgiveness.
Please be assured I did everything in my power to not use that word and does.
I'm sitting here begging your forgiveness for the fact that obviously my efforts
weren't quite good enough.
The BBC did a statement saying it made it absolutely clear to him the standards
and the BBC expects on air and off.
We've left him in no doubt about how seriously we view this.
Okay.
Here's one interesting thing about the editing of a Clarkson's apology is that
what he said was that he,
he did it three times.
He did three takes.
He tried to say that and it sounded like that and he sent a letter to them
making sure that the editors didn't put that in.
So they didn't,
that was 2012 so it's just sort of coming out now.
But,
um,
I didn't even,
I,
I always thought it was tiger.
What do you mean catch a tiger by the toe?
Oh,
I know you've seen that before.
No,
the fucking nursery rhyme.
My daughters use it.
That's how they pick.
They get a little cup of water before
they go to bed at night.
It's like a little ritual.
They like drinking water before they go to bed and they want to choose which one
they get.
So each night one of them would get to Eenie Meenie Miney Mo.
So they'll go eeny meeny miny moe.
But it's catch a tiger.
I've never heard.
That's how I always thought it.
I never even heard of it.
So when you,
when saying this,
you're talking about like the original original,
like this is like a Jim crow slavery nursery rhyme.
Well,
I don't think it is.
I mean he's using it as one,
but I've always heard it is catch a tiger by the toe and you could add a racial
thing.
I've always heard that,
but this might go back that far back might be where you actually got it from
him.
It might be because he's in England,
you know,
in England,
if you,
if it does go back all the way to England,
I mean it might've been one of those things like powdered wigs.
The guy over here,
we swapped it around and you're like,
let's make it tiger.
You shouldn't,
you know,
but he's,
he's also said a lot of dumb racist shit before they were slagging on Mexicans
in the worst way ever.
Once they were just generally talking about I'm making a Mac.
It was about making a Mexican car and then,
and they were joking around about,
could you imagine being born a Mexican?
You know,
what would it be like to be a Mexican and this really bad jokes?
It was pull that shit up,
pull it,
pull it up.
The,
the um,
top gear Mexican remarks.
It was really gross man because it was so obvious that they were trying to set
up jokes.
It was real obvious like for as a comic is it's awkward to watch cause it's real
clunky and then the payoff is just racist racism.
Fuck.
Just total racism.
There wasn't anything good about it.
Mexican car cause the cars reflect national characteristics to others.
So German cars are sort of halo build and and Tommy and caused a bit flamboyant
and quick Mexican cars just going to be lazy,
feckless flats
leaning against the fence asleep looking at a cactus with a blanket with a hole
in the middle.
Donors a coat.
Keep it going cause it gets crazier edited.
So yeah.
Oh it gets crazier.
He says you got the wrong one.
Try.
If you try to find where that goes on from like leaf version,
they shouldn't have that.
Correct.
I've said some racist shit before but this is offensive cars pushed and pulled
ahead of sir cause we already heard most of it can cause to be flamboyant and
quick.
It's skin sportscar 33,000 pounds.
That isn't enough.
Isn't enough because there has been somebody who's paid for that to be developed
and it's got to be shipped.
So it's,
I'd say tell him to quit to the car though.
But they do say,
and they're blurred.
He's got rack and pinion steering.
Wow.
It's got steering.
I'm sorry.
But just imagine waking up and remembering your Mexico
can just,
you can just go
straight back to sleep again.
I'm going to new old day.
That's what I'd be looking to get any complaints about this because the Mexican
embassy,
the ambassador is going to be sitting there with it,
so at,
I won't complain.
It's fine.
Yeah.
Whoops.
This guy,
my Mexican friends did not tolerate this man.
He's been saying racist shit that shows what I'm saying.
Race you shit.
I think it's a good show.
They say funny Shit,
Jeremy Clarkson's hilarious.
But that,
you know,
maybe it's just a different attitude over there.
Maybe it's a cultural thing.
I think it's a superiority complex for sure.
And uh,
just the fact that,
I guess when,
when did that episode a year?
Couple of years ago,
I think it was black.
There was some blow back but not enough to cancel it.
They just said it was the number one show,
reality show in the world,
essentially non scripted show in the world.
But it is scripted.
It's obviously scripted.
That was all scripted.
All that shit mean.
Did they say nonfiction?
Is that what they said?
Whatever it is.
Nonfiction non-scripted that was so obviously scripted.
It was gross.
And that whole thing of imagine waking up and remembering your Mexican,
that is a crazy thing to say.
Stone cold say that.
The Oscar de la Hoya,
you know.
See that's the most ridiculous thing to say ever.
The idea that that would be enough to be a joke,
like a set up and a punchline.
And the audience was laughing too.
So it's like,
I don't even like where Mexican comics make Mexican jokes,
you know?
Um,
uh,
Anthony Bordain put a Tumblr blog entry recently,
like yesterday about Mexico,
about how crazy is it that we love Mexican food.
We love their style of clothing.
We love a lot of their architecture.
We love all these different things about Mexico and about that come from Mexico.
But we don't love Mexico.
Like what is it like that Mexico has this negative connotation.
They,
he just goes into like how important their culture has been food wise.
Whenever he worked at a restaurant I was always the Mexicans that hooked him up
and helped him out and some of the hardest working people he's ever met and the
most dedicated to to cooking all these different things and he made this great
point like what the fuck is it about us that has this weird prejudice towards
Mexico and Mexican people when so much great shit has come from that culture.
Like clearly it's a country that's in turmoil financially and in leadership wise
and the drug war and all that.
I mean there's obviously problems with Mexico but to ignore all the amazing shit
that they've created.
And I mean just go all the way back to when you know the Aztecs were building
these gigantic fucking pyramids here.
It's beautiful structures.
Go back to them,
the Mayans all the same essentially.
I mean all that eventually became the people of Mexico.
If you go down to like Cheech and eatsa where the Mayan temple is,
you still see people that are,
they're Mayan man,
right?
I mean you can call Mexico if you want,
but they're like four foot five and they have these crazy like long like,
like American Indian looking faces.
Like they look very different.
Like there's some people down like in the Yucatan that they're essentially
descendants of the Mayans.
Man.
I mean that is a part of Mexican culture.
And Anthony Bordain makes a really interesting point about that.
That's a,
that's a dope article.
I'm going to stop being racist because now he's right.
As far as the article is concerned,
it's just,
you know,
I think racism is like the main ingredient.
Twitters is insecurity and just,
you know,
just in anything,
even in comedy or anything,
people always find a way to put themselves above another person.
Sometimes that involves color and race and sometimes people with money,
you know,
there might be somebody else the same color and they have more money and they'll
find a way to put them down.
So there's classism,
but it's all rooted in insecurity.
And they could do a lot of damage.
It just fucked up.
It is fucked up.
And you know what else you see?
It is weird.
A weird place.
You see it with famous people,
right?
Like do you ever be hanging around with a couple of famous dudes and a more
famous personal walk in and just Trump the famous person again,
have to just of those like Fox events were all these like actors all get
together and they were like,
they have like a,
like almost like a pecking order and they'll,
they'll treat the other ones like shit because this one's on a TV show.
Like these two guys.
I watched these two guys argue once and one of them was an actor who did films
and the other one was an actor who did tell her shit.
And the actor who did films was saying,
no,
you do shit.
I do films.
Don't say you do what I do.
And they were like,
what can they do it like he was like saying,
you do you do television?
I do films.
And they were,
they were bitching at each other.
And that's what they were using.
The one guy was holding over the TV stars head.
He's a loser.
He is a fucking TV show and some days calling him a loser.
I could understand him.
He was talking to a soap opera star,
but come on man.
Even if you worked,
did you hear about that soap operas started.
Did a Iowasca any fucking quit his job.
Oh for real?
Yeah.
Some do on days of our lives.
She was like,
fuck this.
He did IOWASCA tripped his balls off.
Opened up.
Yeah.
He got an open way the fuck up.
He came back and he said,
this is just nonsense.
I'm not doing this anymore.
Right?
Yeah.
There he is.
You quit days of awesome.
How long has he been on there?
I don't know if he's been on there.
They all want to quit though,
man.
I had a buddy who was on a soap opera for a long time.
He fucking hated it.
He'd rather not worked and be on a soap opera.
Why did he do it?
Keep doing it too.
Was trying to just,
he was trying to be an actor and you know when you're trying to be an actor and
you have the choice,
you can work as a bartender or you could work as a soap star.
You're like,
oh well you know what?
A lot of people who've made it from soap star legitimate,
but there's a certain amount of time you can,
you can only,
you have to bail.
Like as far as like the industry classism,
I think they look at you.
If you're on a soap for too long,
they go,
this motherfucker's or so
it's like the fact guy thing.
It's talking about you
soap opera,
they actor.
Listen you,
you've been a villain on this soap opera.
It's been amazing.
Right?
For 50 years and you're going to continue to do that.
Like no,
no,
I'm,
I'm about to break out box come mainstream now.
We don't allow it.
Yeah.
I get that.
I get that too.
Do you?
Yeah.
Not,
not the villain thing,
but like when I went to Montreal the last time,
two years at the comedy festival comedy festival,
it didn't matter how good I did,
they were looking at 25 year olds and anybody who was older who was a star,
if you fell in the middle like me,
Zach,
Saran over you,
like,
like you're like,
you're done.
You didn't do it at the time.
Like it was just that.
But if you were 25 and had one good joke in your,
in your set,
then it's,
it was,
it's like the youth rush.
That's interesting.
And it,
but it was,
it was good for me to see that.
And that was like that.
And a few other things is like,
all right,
I got to figure out a way to get my shit together.
That's really fascinating.
He man,
so that's just like what they're selling,
right?
They're just trying to sell.
There's trying to sell you
young,
right?
Yeah,
they are.
It's selling youth.
And,
uh,
my manager spoke to my ex agent when it,
like I had the agent before I had the manager and my manager's like,
we got to get even more money for these college gigs or these,
these shows and uh,
about my agent told my manager,
Ian's time has passed.
It's the most you can get from him.
Whoa.
Funny.
Didn't matter.
Nothing.
You know,
it's really stupid about that at all.
All the things that you do like as an art form [inaudible] the being a comedian,
like being young is probably the least important because being older you're
going to have more knowledge,
right?
You didn't have more opinions on things and you recognize bullshit easier.
You'll see the bullshit in yourself,
you recognize you,
but you just become so much better as you get older as a comic that the young
guys like,
man,
when I was 21,
I always say this,
I sucked.
I was a terrible comedian and one of the reasons why I was a terrible comedian
is fucking everybody's terrible when they're 21.
Right?
You might have a couple of good jokes.
You might have a couple of the he he's,
and so when you start making points,
if you're making a point about anything and your 21 nobody wants to listen to
you,
dude,
you're too dumb because very few people that are 21 years old that can carry a
nuanced point on stage in front of a room full of strangers about a
controversial issue and say it in a way it's going to make everybody laugh
hysterically.
It's rare.
You got your rare Chappelle's you got your rare,
you know I'm sure Eddie Murphy when he was young it was crushing.
It wasn't as like,
it wasn't
poignant but he was,
he had that funding [inaudible]
killing it but for the most part,
most 21 year olds are dark shit.
Right.
They just dog shit their kids,
they don't know any of that.
They don't know anything yet but,
but the built the business doesn't care.
It was like,
and to me funny is young,
as long as you're funny.
It's young.
Like people just want to laugh and if you're funny they don't give a fuck how
old you are.
Like this guy.
Like when I was a kid,
I was watching Benny Hill because he was fucking funny.
His age never mattered to me,
but now they are making that shit.
Well I think they want to sell you like a symbol.
You know that girls are going to get into you.
It's,
they're going to,
you know,
it's going to be like when Dane Cook was in as my space prime,
they're going to flock to see your shows.
Oh my God.
And you got to admit that that's a,
an attractant.
Whether it's as a singer,
it's attracting as an actor and she could be as a comedian too,
right?
But not if you're really into standup comedy.
And if you're really into standup comedy,
you go to see Louis C K he's in his forties he's fat and he's hilarious.
And he's attracted everybody.
You're trying to attract to be attracted to those 20 something year olds.
So,
but,
and when he was 30 he wasn't doing so well.
Right.
So when he was,
you know,
he's probably like,
I think he's older than me.
I'm 46 so I think he's 47 or something like that.
So when he was 36 37,
nobody gave a fuck about him.
It's the sort of same situation and now look,
boom,
you know,
arguably the number one comic in the world.
So,
and then you got David towl better now than ever.
Right.
Better now than ever.
And he's 50 and there's rock still go in and just going.
I just,
there's tons of people.
Yeah.
Even fucking Jerry Seinfeld,
he's like 62 there,
you know,
I mean,
when,
when a comic learns how to be a comic,
I keep hearing and I need to see him to see it myself.
Like bill Cosby.
Yes.
I hear the same shit.
I need to see him too.
Let's go see him.
Okay.
Let's find out when he is here and yeah,
I keep hearing that.
Yeah.
I keep hearing that he's killing it.
I keep hearing he's killing it and I'm hearing it from people outside.
Showbusiness I held it from a dude I know in Austin.
He's not,
has nothing to do with show business.
Right.
And,
uh,
he was telling me,
he's like,
me and my friends would see bill Cosby.
I'll log,
what was it like?
He's like,
dude,
he goes,
you wouldn't believe it man.
He goes,
he,
he's telling these stories.
At first you're like,
man,
these fucking stories.
He'd taken a long time.
He goes and then five minutes and you are fucking crying,
laugh.
And then you realize how he's tying all these stories in together and you're
like,
I'm watching a master doesn't have an opening act goes on stage by himself.
Right.
He does like 90 minutes,
two hours,
just him himself and it's captivating.
That's the Shit I've been hearing.
Keep hearing it.
I don't hear anybody saying it's bad.
Nobody.
No.
I'm hearing over and over again that it's killer.
He's like 80 years old.
He's getting street reviews.
Yeah.
What?
Oh,
like word of mouth.
That's amazing.
Like word of mouth is like an underground young band coming up.
So that's what I'm saying.
Funny transcends
like you're hearing the same thing.
I'm hearing that I have a few friends,
I went to see him and they're like,
you got to see him.
And it's on my,
one of my list of things to go see.
It's like going to Coachella.
I gotta go see this dude.
Yeah,
we got to see him before.
Okay.
Check this out.
I think I'm going to be in Vegas when he's there.
Oh Shit.
Hold on a second.
It's um,
there's a UFC on the 24th and Bill Cosby is in Vegas on the 23rd.
Oh Shit.
Perfect.
Treasure island showroom.
Please tell me you want to,
I'll come out there know not in Vegas.
All right,
cool.
I'm not do it with me.
If you want,
I'll get you tickets to the UFC to its next.
I'll do that to boom again.
Yeah.
Do you want to see Cosby?
Are you gonna fuck yeah,
you have the attention span,
but it is kind of,
it's not really standard visit though.
It's kind of like a one man play.
I don't know.
I don't even want to judge what it is.
I don't know what it is,
but I need to find out if I can get to,
it's funny,
I wanted to defend what it is and I don't even know.
All right.
We'll talk about this after.
But I'm just like,
now that I know that this is a possibility and it's a night at half off perfect.
Wayne's during the day and then the nighttime I have off but it's probably about
like a six o'clock show tickets available.
Oh people probably falsely says a 8:00 PM Oh shit.
They're staying awake.
Oh my God.
Who's there next week man.
See Ya
right after bill copy birthday cardio.
That is ironic as fuck.
Cause he took a Mitzia took a Cosby joke to him.
That was the final nail in the [inaudible] on the
coffin when people saw him do a bill copy.
That's hilarious.
And wonder bill thinks when he sees that he probably doesn't even know.
He probably didn't even fucking heard about the video and he probably has no
idea that it got busted stealing his joke.
So I doubt he pays attention to it at all.
But apparently the motherfucker keeps writing and I say motherfucker with all
due respect.
Yeah.
Is there a tickets still available?
I don't know.
We'll find out after the show.
I don't want to be investigating during the program,
but um,
I think that's a great idea,
man.
I really need to see it because I keep hearing it,
Chris Rock was the first one I heard it from.
Yeah.
He said that shit to Seinfeld said it.
Chris Rock was a fascinating name,
shaking his head and he goes,
ah.
He goes,
I felt like I was like an amateur.
Watch that guy up there.
Cause I felt like I was an amateur.
I was like,
wow,
that's crazy.
And he goes,
he goes up there with no,
no,
no opening act.
That's like an hour and a half by himself.
Said it was amazing.
I was like,
wow,
that's incredible.
What do you know what some one thing if this guy who was my friend in Austin
says it,
but when that guy says exactly the same thing as Chris rock gotta listen,
you gotta go to something,
something's going on.
And I would assume Chris rock is pretty critical.
How do you not be,
I mean,
he's an icon for sure.
Like,
I've heard people say,
there's some old dudes that were really funny that really weren't funny.
There was a few guys,
oh my God,
you never seen,
he's hilarious and you seem it's dog shit.
It's just,
he's just an old dude that people like,
people don't want to say nothing bad about it.
They don't want to say,
I'd be disappointed that this didn't live up to it.
Now we put all this hype behind it.
We're going to have to get drunk
to get hammered and make it even better and then embarrass ourselves by trying
to meet him and getting shut down.
We went to see dice backstage.
We went to see a dice rather,
um,
at the um,
uh,
the Riviera,
which is one of the best places to see him cause it's all old school and it's
upstairs and it was Jim Norton and Anthony Cohlmia and Brian and me and we all
had off.
We,
nobody had to work.
So it was just,
it was a treat just to be able to sit there and watch dice.
And then we went backstage and was like talking to him like this might be one of
the coolest things I've ever done.
Gone to see a show and then gone backstage to hang out with dice clay after a
show in Vegas.
It was really cool,
but dice knows me.
Bill Cosby would just kick us right then.
Scrubs.
Fuck out of here.
I'll causing my,
yeah.
Jello pudding.
Red Bands are going to start doing his own thing.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
They're definitely gonna get kicked out.
Imagine if you did that in his room.
He would beat you to death
with sinks.
Bill Cosby,
Bill Cosby Beats Brian.
Read married with a lamp,
picks up the lamp and breaks it over your head and then stabs you in the neck
with the broken pieces.
Is there even any footage of bill Cosby versus heckler?
I Bet I would love to see what he would,
his response to that would be they probably don't allow hecklers at his shows on
those fucking people so quick.
Yeah,
he's,
I mean,
he's not doing that kind of comedy.
He's doing the kind of comedy where it's like these long monologues that are
stories,
you know,
that he's crap crafted and molded to like the perfect amount of words he,
he used to,
it's kind of fascinating.
I mean now he's doing shows,
obviously if you go to bill cosby.com a lot of shows,
he's got a lot of shows planned out like over and over,
like May 9th two shows in a night.
On May 9th May 10th he's got a show May 11th may,
I mean he's working.
I don't think if I had his money,
there's no way I'd still be doing.
I think he enjoys it,
but got it.
What I'm hearing is,
or what I was hearing before he,
he was doing all these shows was that he would go and do like a,
like a tonight show or a Letterman appearance,
one of those type of things.
He didn't even practice the material.
He would just write it to write it himself and he would work on it himself and
then he would go onto these shows and just do it.
The first time he was doing it was on live TV and they would say,
you know,
don't you go to the comedy clubs and practice like,
I ain't know how to do comedy.
Like his,
in his mind,
he knew how to discern what was good,
what was bad,
crafted all himself and then release it into the wild.
I had enough practice.
He trusted himself
and he,
I guess he's honest enough with themselves to say,
this is funny.
It's not funny.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
In and of itself.
That's a,
that's an interesting point of view.
I mean,
I guess you get to,
it sounds,
oh z,
right?
Fuck yeah,
it does.
It sounds ballsy,
but you should.
Yeah.
Like you said,
when you get to a certain age,
you should know,
but it still sounds ballsy and appoint that I'm not definitely not it.
Yeah.
Real,
real,
ballsy.
But he also got in some trouble,
man.
There was some,
he had to settle a lawsuit.
Someone accusing him of,
there was like some drug thing,
some date rape pills.
Yeah.
Well,
girls,
again,
man,
sexual assault allegations
doesn't matter who you are.
You cannot escape vagina.
We'll get you.
We'll get you,
man.
Maybe we answered the question like why is he still doing stand that pay off
these suits,
pay off these suits.
That's probably a big factor.
And then on top of that,
it probably,
because he can still get some pussy on the road
and I still bill Cosby,
Bill Cosby at man,
it's still nothing better than road pussy.
Isn't that amazing?
That's ridiculous.
Could you imagine if that was the case?
If you pulled him aside and he said,
Bill,
it's amazing that you're still doing all these shows.
Like what's up?
I got two words for you
and it gives you
the impression do it,
but is it,
and I'm not even going to press this as a terrible bill Cosby,
but it's better than mine.
That's what I've never tried to do.
Jello pudding.
I sound like Red Fox.
Oh Man.
I need to rethink my cosmic impression.
Yeah,
he's,
he's on stage.
This is just some fascinating shit.
He's got a hearing aid on.
No Shit.
It's just somebody reading in the lines,
but look at,
he's got this thing.
I mean it looks like a hearing aid.
I mean what is that?
He's old man.
Damn.
Yeah,
it's old.
Yeah.
I mean he's like,
it's got like this wired thing.
Maybe it's a so he could hear what the audience is hearing.
It might be that.
Is that his microphone?
Cause you have a mic in front of him or,
I don't know.
It's hard to tell.
It's a weird picture.
It looks,
it doesn't look like a microphone in his hand unless he uses a really tiny
microphone.
But it's lip syncs.
The whole thing.
Imagine if he does because he's so old.
That's how he does it.
He doesn't like,
like Britney Spears does commercial concerts.
Can you imagine if a Guy Lipsync standup?
Has anyone ever done that before?
I'd asked,
but it's hilarious.
That would be so hard.
It's so hard to do to,
to lip sync your stand up.
Cause I do a different every night.
I just know where it'd be able to lip sync it like it never glass drops.
You keep going have keep going and play it off.
But you didn't hear it.
Places on fire.
You're still going.
I'm going to do my act in the back.
If you don't burn alive,
but please laugh.
People were running out to do the heroes soundtrack.
This is a fucking laugh track.
No one's laughing.
We're on fire.
And then I wasn't like,
hi mom.
Hello.
It'd be funny shit.
I'm sure someone's done it cause anyone ever juice the audience before?
Has anybody ever used like a laugh track?
Like whether on stage that that sounds disgusting.
That's him.
Must've been done.
Must have been done.
Somebody must've done it.
If you can think of it,
somebody must have done it.
People are always accusing people of planting,
putting a plant in the audience.
Heckles says something stupid.
So the guy on stage give a perfect thing to say to him.
Like Deco wasn't,
he's a plant,
they planted them in the audience.
Now I'm sure that's happened because I've heard of it happening and like sort of
like fake like performance art type scenarios and shows.
But uh,
I know it happens when you watch most comedy central specials.
I,
you could hear the cheap can't like why can't comedy central used better canned
laughter.
So they have canned laughter you think?
Did they do like over there standup specials?
Like if you listen,
you could,
you could hear like all the audiences from all the special sound the same,
which is impossible.
It's impossible.
Like they all laugh the same way.
There's that one show a that uses the young standups and the whole audience is
just canned.
Laughter is what's really suck is,
I don't want to say this,
I guess they just don't say it all right.
What's the show?
But,
but I guess because there was even jokes that were so dumb that you can't,
you can't even,
you know that there's no one going to be laughing at this and it just explodes.
Like they just got off stage and you're just like,
what the fuck is this shit?
Wow.
And it's edited to where the audience like is still laughing,
but it goes on to like the next choke.
Like it's just how it's edited.
You could just tell,
I forgot the African name of the show.
I don't wanna say it.
Yeah.
You don't have to say the name.
That's kind of fucked up.
Right.
That's a boy.
That's one of those weird like what's the line?
What's deceptive and what is just editing when you start adding laughter to a
comedy show,
like a laugh track on sitcoms.
Okay.
For some reason.
Why is that?
Why the fuck is a tray?
That's not,
that's not okay either.
It's not okay if she gets big,
it gets annoying too is like,
especially when there's laughter where you know that's not a joke.
Yeah.
If you want to know how stupid it is,
watch one of those Disney shows.
What was Disney shows the last big one.
And the guy comes in with the flip flop side in your life
and everybody's like,
Woo.
The
really bad laugh track scenes are offensive.
They hurt,
they hurt since so hurt.
They're insulting.
It's offensive.
It's a fact.
You heard the culture,
you,
if anybody who can listen to this and really believe that that's real laughter
is either very,
very young,
which is rude cause you do like a Shitty,
shitty joke on children or they're idiots.
So those are the two options.
Either someone's really young and you're treating them like they're fools.
And You giving them bad entertainment and giving them really low standards to
behave by or you're making movies and shows for idiots and it,
yeah,
it definitely giving them like low standards
to live by or for sure.
Oh they don't give a fuck man.
Like they don't trust,
they just don't trust like,
you know,
like make something good.
Just put it out there in and trust it.
But it's also that there's a lot of dummies out there that like bad shit that
there's just a lot of that man and a lot of these sitcoms that are really like
Brian coulombs hope my house.
And we were talking about sitcoms that he did and he was,
he was just shaking his head.
He was like so bad.
He goes,
I'm doing the show.
I can't fucking believe this is a sitcom.
I can't believe how bad it is.
And he did like a couple of episodes and he was telling me about it and he was
like,
the people like they're convincing themselves.
He goes,
the actors on the set or laughing and the show does well on TV and he's like,
and it's shit,
it's terrible.
And I was like,
what is that?
And he goes,
I don't know.
We were trying to figure it out.
I'm like,
is it just desserts?
Just a lot of really dumb mother fuckers out there.
And that just hits their frequency.
And so the disease,
clever people that know the right frequency for dumb people,
you know,
where would I be without you hunting?
Probably know where goodnight fade to black dirt,
Marto w whatever it is,
man,
it's popular.
Well there's,
you know,
there's,
there's no lack of stupid people in this world.
Like when I was watching like,
uh,
I think it was on e years ago,
maybe even 10 years ago.
And that's talking about Gilligan's island and PPS.
So riding,
so said,
please rescue those people.
Bluff the eyes.
Like nobody gonna help.
Like real letters.
I'm not even making this up.
It's real.
No,
I'm sure.
But we're worried about them.
But watching him every week,
they're out there on that island by themselves.
It's going to be a monsoon out.
We need your help.
Those people,
there's a month soon.
Nice Foy.
Those people raise kids.
Yeah.
They raise kids to go out there and harass your kids.
Well this,
but do you think that a show that's a dumb show actually influences the culture
enough to have an effect on it?
Because if that's the case,
and I'm guilty too for fear factor,
if there,
if a show can be so dumb and lower standards so much and its delivery in the
shitty jokes and the canned laughter and just just as low rpm entertainment
[inaudible] Ma and sucks you into its fucking more of soap opera stupidity.
If,
if that,
if it is,
is it possible that that can actual actually lower a collective intelligence of
any part of a culture?
Well,
it won't improve it.
You could,
you could go where you want to go from there.
And I don't,
I don't think like I've heard you're being a hard on fear factor before,
but that shit interesting.
Well it was,
it is definitely a little different and it's stupidity,
but it's still stupidity.
It's,
yeah.
But here's the thing about fear factor.
It was you at home,
putting yourself in these people's situation like in in the day and you're
wondering what anything that makes you kind of say,
could I do that?
And you watch somebody go through it and do it.
It,
it's,
it's just there's,
there's something interesting about fear factor that I wouldn't just brush off,
you know,
they call it,
there's an ingredient in there that's,
that's important that you know that,
that people can use on other things,
but there's something definitely there to make people keep watching it.
It's not,
even though the 50 it wasn't even when somebody at the end and got the $50,000
it's the,
they did all this.
Even if you're,
you can look at it,
there's different types of people that watched it to say,
these people are stupid or I can't believe this person just ate that or did that
people or just,
just the interest in things that people go through,
watching people go through what they're going to go through.
It's just,
it's,
there's a lot of shit there,
man.
Well,
there's a psychological battles that are going on when you see people trying to
eat blended rats or climb up buildings and the fucking terrified of heights or
swim when they can't swim.
There's a lot of psychological shit going on.
And then there's also just the fact that they really are,
whatever they're doing,
as ridiculous as it is,
they really are competing,
right?
It's a human competition.
Whenever you're watching any sort of competition,
it becomes compelling,
right?
Because you try to figure out what you would do and you get caught up like we
were talking about.
What was the dude's name that were saying Clark live in Clark's life?
Was it Clark?
Oh yeah.
What does,
what do we call it?
Carl.
If you were living in Carl's life,
what's compelling about it?
Besides the fact that you get to experience someone else's life,
as you probably get your own mind as well.
Thank fuck,
would I do this?
Oh my God,
I am is crazy.
I can't believe you did fuck this chick.
He doesn't even call you crazy.
They're watching cause chased calls.
The condoms tore down.
Doesn't mean you're supposed to just fuck.
Yeah.
What's calls who
crazy shit that you would never do live vicariously and that's what that,
you know,
fear factor gave people an experienced man.
It was definitely an experience for me.
It was surreal because I,
you know,
it was there.
Why was all happening like can't even book and then I watched it on TV and I
just leave my house,
shaved my head.
I can't believe I'm like,
as I was doing,
I was like this is the most ridiculous shit of all time.
I can't believe this is a job.
Plus plus
like it's like a survivor.
Like when survivor first came on I said I'm going to watch this shit tonight and
laugh at how dumb this thing is.
But the execution of the first episode blew my mind and I watched the entire
season.
I agree.
And I was like,
and I think you guys had good execution.
They definitely know what they were doing.
Yeah.
David and Matt Q in Institute dudes that were in charge of the whole thing,
they knew what the fuck they were doing.
They did.
They both have done TV for the longest time,
but I think that helps for sure.
But this is something about watching people compete.
It's so fucking compelling.
That's why people like sports.
Yeah.
That's why people like watching basketball.
That's why people like watching MMA.
People love watching people.
Okay.
Heat that'll,
that'll never end.
And then it was attractive people too.
And people who are like,
oh that's the person from next door,
whatever.
That's worth.
Cause people like the normal person and then the real world was hot.
So it's like these are all the people who auditioned for real world and then get
on it.
They can do,
they can do,
they can do have power over you.
Yeah.
Like you'll think about how weird it is that we like watching people compete so
much.
We will watch people run.
Yeah.
Running is one of the most boring fucking things you could ever watch.
Person to go left.
Right,
left,
right.
No.
Golf at least varies a little bit more than running.
Like the,
the best thing that can happen as far as excitement goes.
Obviously the worst thing to the person.
But the best thing for the viewer is watching a race where a bunch of people
fall on top of each other.
One person or the best.
It's the worst for the people involved,
but at home you're like,
oh shit,
this is crazy.
The casual person does have anything invested in the race would be their heart
rate would go up.
If I saw a bunch of 30 people fall and pile on top of each other in the
beginning of all of a sudden the interest in it goes up.
Yeah,
it would be on TV every fucking 15 minutes for 24 hours.
He would see those people trip and fall on top of each other.
A terrible start today to the Boston marathon.
Just a year from the tragic terrorist event.
We got a pile up at the finish line and a bunch of people just stumble on top of
each other and break hips,
twist ankles.
They would play that shit,
but over and over and over.
I know they're still looking for a fucking plane that's it's on the news every
day,
all day long.
A fucking plane that disappeared seven weeks ago.
There's no story.
There's no information that's new.
There's no pictures,
there's no metal.
Every day.
A new chapter in the Malaysian airlines,
the new week eight,
the news milk that for ratings,
it's the craziest.
Don't care about those all the time.
The craziest milking of all time.
It's like he just like the Jody areas trial.
It's like why they made us or made,
I didn't care.
But they made people care about the results of this case is Jody Eris,
was she hot?
She did.
She was hot.
Which ones?
She,
she was,
she was pushing for a murderer.
She murdered her boyfriend and then the one the year before the year before.
So the missing plane is just Jody areas or the thing they slipped in.
Slipped in place of.
There's no Katrina.
So let's do the plane.
There's no,
that hot chick has killed her man.
Like some regular people who have killed their man.
So let's do the plane.
Yeah.
How many regular people killed their men in between the time where Jody areas
killed her man and the plane crashed,
right?
Probably all,
yeah.
Really not
hot.
It didn't have,
they didn't have good PR.
They didn't get out there.
Pr.
I used to do a joke about Manson,
about how Manson is like the Bob hope of serial killers,
but everybody says Bob hope was a comedian when I was a kid.
Like buffalo never made me laugh.
I'm not laughing.
I get Charlie Chaplin.
I understood the three Sturges,
Bob Hope.
I'd be like,
what are you laughing at?
But like when you talk about like serial killers,
everybody's like,
oh,
he's fucking Manson.
The guys like Manson.
I beat the fuck out of Manson.
Manson never talked shit to me.
If he got crazy with me,
I would fucking Manson up.
He's like five feet tall.
He weighs a hundred pounds.
He didn't even kill anybody.
He got other people to kill people for him.
You got to Tex Watson to do all the murders and all those other squeaky Fromme
would tried to kill a Gerald Ford.
I'm not scared of Manson,
but I was like,
during the whole time there's been all these serial killers that have killed way
more people and you never hear about that.
And the joke was that Henry Lee Lucas,
he's the guy that they made that movie Henry Portrait of a serial killer about,
he was with the dude from walking dead.
The brother,
not the guy,
not the guy who shoots the crossbows,
but his brother.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I know you told him the one that's hands missing.
Yes.
That guy,
he played Henry Lee.
Lucas and Mike can really look as killed 60 fucking people and everyone's
Manson.
He's like,
man,
the guys are gonna.
He goes,
no,
what do I have to do to get a little attention?
I killed 64 it's disrespectful cause it's real serious,
but you've got 65 buddies.
It's like a dude who won like an amateur boxing championship and they've
compared them to Muhammad Ali.
Oh,
that's funny.
They just,
they're just talking about him all the time.
They don't talk about Ali.
What about me bitch?
You fucking crazy.
Like good.
I did want the title three times.
This dude,
one of the amateur thing.
Yeah,
that's what it's like.
that's fucked up.
But the Manson thing,
I guess it was the cult leader,
part of it was,
which freaked everybody out because people were terrified by someone who could
lead people astray.
Right.
And it was the time,
and I think he was a Hippie,
right?
There's,
yeah,
there's a lot of things that they take out of the story that they don't focus on
now.
Like back then maybe,
I don't know,
it feels like just on instinct that they wanted to condemn hippies back then,
100% so they use this guy to condemn hippies,
like the,
you know,
the suits and then,
then now that part of the story is gone,
you know?
And,
and now it's just fascinating.
It told residually fascinating.
But back then it could have been a big story for what was the reason why,
why?
That was a big story back then because there was a lot
dark shit that happened when there was a murdered pregnant woman who was also a
movie star,
Sharon Tate.
That was,
it struck home with a lot of good elements.
Yeah.
And then Roman Polanski,
it was his wife that was murdered.
A lot of people didn't know that.
And then Roman Polanski turns out to be a child molester and he plays on his
crazy connections to that,
that murder,
they wrote war or die pig or something like that and blood on the wall.
So what was the name of the of color you mentioned Henry Lee Lucas.
So this is what he was doing.
I didn't
do it.
Regular people,
it's killing like diner waitresses and shit.
Yeah,
that's what he would do.
He'd just go across the country and just kill people randomly.
He's a guy would walk into the bathroom,
a look,
a restaurant bathroom and he was just decided I'm going to go kill this
motherfucker,
go in Shank the guy,
stabbed a bunch of times and go out and eat his meal.
Like nothing happened.
And people start screaming and uh,
he would go one,
what's going on?
Like this is like in the 70s,
the 80s.
And then there was,
nobody knew what the fuck was going on and there's nothing,
you know,
they didn't get your fingerprints,
he didn't know shit.
And he would kill people randomly.
And apparently random killers are the hardest to capture.
The hardest to like if you've got a person who's a real crazy person who just
not the plot's not that says,
you know what,
this Brian Red Van Motherfucker,
I gotta,
I can't take it shit on the podcast anymore.
I'm going to fucking track them down.
But if it's,
I'm gonna put this camera,
this tape recorded behind the toilet,
it's someone who gets in their car.
It's something that gets in their car and says,
let me just decide who I'm going to kill today.
And they just drive around and go,
okay,
that's the guy.
And they just get out and they shoot them and they just get in the car and drive
away.
It's very difficult to catch that guy,
right,
because then they'll news,
as I say,
that's been a gang murder.
It could be.
It could be a random,
I mean it depends on what city you're in too.
Like,
what if you're in Chicago,
like if you wanted to be a murderer,
like a serial killer,
you go to the south side of Chicago,
just drive around and start killing people at random.
It's happening over there anyway,
right?
It's like there's so much murder.
They're like Louisiana,
New Orleans.
We were there.
This guy who was there who had told me about,
he had lived through the,
uh,
Katrina floods and he was talking about the,
the level of violence that he saw and he said,
well,
just cops shooting people and craziness and just riding.
It was like,
he goes,
it was crazy.
Like if you just inter,
you know,
inserted yourself into some sort of chaotic situation like that and just
randomly killed a person,
they never catch you.
He just swoop right back into the back into the darkness,
you know?
That's,
that kind of serial killer stuff was really scary to people.
The idea that someone could just not value life so much or get such a thrill out
of killing someone that they're just willing to do that.
It's like kill people.
Like is masturbating,
like,
is this the only good thing,
you know,
you could say about like a scenario like that is that most of those people you
would think it's not even a good thing,
but I would imagine that a lot of them trip up because there are so amoral and
so fucked up.
Like that was the whole theme of the,
um,
uh,
the,
American serial killer book,
American Psycho.
Did you ever read the book?
The book is way more graphic and fucked up then the movie,
the movie's fucked up,
but you only have so much time in a movie to go into how crazy guy is.
But Bret Easton Ellis in the book had hundreds of pages and that it was dark,
dark,
dark shit.
A real story.
No,
it's fictional,
totally fiction.
It was sort of a metaphor for the,
uh,
the cocaine mindset of the 80s and the materialist mindset of stockbrokers and
this,
and he just had created this guy who inserted himself into this world who's just
a complete and total psychopath serial killer.
Fascinating Shit.
Because the guy like,
it's almost like he's getting more,
the thrills don't come unless he's more and more reckless now because you get
tired of doing it this way and then you want to do it that way and then you
gotta to kick it up a notch in order to get your thrill.
And a lot of them that happens,
they ramp up until they eventually get busted and just,
they just,
they,
they don't get satisfied with just one type of thrill.
Yeah.
But then there's like,
dudes like the Zodiac killer.
They never catch.
Yeah.
He's just stayed in his own.
He's just smarter spot kept his protocol.
Even made letters,
sent them letters and shit.
Did you ever see that?
Was it Jake Loyola?
I in hall on golf?
Is that him?
Who did the Zodiac movie?
Yeah,
he does a,
Charles Fleischer was in that movie.
Was He?
Yeah.
Thanks.
So Charles Pfizer,
it might be the fucking Zodiac killer.
How about that?
Yeah.
He might've been in a movie about himself.
Charles Fleischer came to the back of the comedy store one night and handed me
some fucking thing that he created with plastic that was a new geometric shape.
I just asked him about that.
Yeah,
he said it.
He invented it some sort of with mathematics invented some sort of a new GM unto
heard.
Never heard unto her to geometric shape before and to heard.
Is that the,
how you say it?
Spending that Roger Rabbit money?
Yeah.
I think that money's gone.
But he was a weird cat.
You know?
Fleischer was a smart dude.
He would in his spare time,
he like read books on astronomy and Shit and come to backstage,
the comic store,
that back Patio area.
We'd always talk about space.
I mean,
yeah.
Wild conversations about space and science.
He's a fucking,
he was more into that than he wasn't this doing stand up.
Yes.
Yeah.
Is He,
how is he financially now?
I haven't seen him in forever,
man.
I see him.
He always looks good and he always has like a younger girl with him.
Ha.
Ah,
let's see him once in a while.
That's funny.
They used to be a dude who,
uh,
was an older guy.
He used to come to the comic store.
He's tried to hypnotize girls.
That was his move and um,
I'd always heard it.
And then one day,
I mean the main room,
you know,
the back area of the main room,
but where the ticket thing is in this comic is saying something,
this woman.
So he leans over and she goes,
no,
I don't want you to hypnotize me.
And I just started laughing.
It's fucking true.
He was asking her if he could hypnotize.
Yeah.
What a pleasant guy ass.
Right.
I think you have to,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't think you can,
you can't just hypnotize someone.
You have to ask to hypnotize them cause they have to like put themselves in the
mindset like okay,
I'm about to be hypnotized.
I don't think it's like one of those you're getting sleepy,
sleepy.
Oh my God.
It's in troll my mind.
I don't think that works.
If she's in the bathroom,
I don't think it works.
Imagine that you have a tape recording.
You got any sleep?
Are you allowed to do that?
We not allowed to record,
but all you're allowed to project it allowed to broadcast secretly when someone
doesn't know.
Are you allowed to have,
have you talking in a bathroom?
I think that if I was,
um,
I mean,
when it comes to laws like about recording laws,
eventually we're going to have to abandon that.
If everybody's just starts recording everything,
right.
Everything already is,
or one's recording people with their phones.
That would be the one thing that holds you back.
Right?
B,
you,
if you have two people and one of them consent and the other one doesn't consent
or doesn't know they're being recorded.
When you always know you're being recorded because you're always being recorded,
all those laws are going to have to change.
Right.
Does that make sense?
The fucked up thing is that it doesn't even matter.
It's like once somebody released the tape,
you're screwed socially.
Yeah.
You're all condemned or whatever.
It's like,
well,
unless you don't say anything fucked up.
Right.
With how,
I just think it's hard to not say something fucked up.
Yeah.
Well,
there's definitely hard,
especially when you're an 81 year old racist,
you know,
if you really stop and think about it,
that dude was 60 years old when the Internet became pop.
Damn.
That's funny.
It's crazy step in there.
That's what he was stepping.
Their seed is 60 years old,
but not credible.
But I think I'm a decent person,
but I know you could probably play some shit back.
Okay.
From conversations that I said and you could,
somebody could hang me [inaudible]
oh definitely.
Especially if they did it the way that Jerry called Jeremy Clarkson thing did.
Well,
you just take one snippet of it.
That sounds so stupid.
I did everything within my power to not say that word.
The fuck you did not do it at all.
He was saying is I did everything in my power to not say that word on television
and that clip never made TV like he was trying.
He went to his long,
but they were like,
yeah,
whatever junk.
They ticked it the most ridiculous salacious chunk and they put it in right.
I did everything within my power.
Apparently that wasn't enough.
Could you imagine?
He just has racist Tourette's.
He was like trying really hard to hold.
I'm Mexican.
He's trying so hard to hide in it.
He's trying,
he's trying so hard not to say it,
but he can't.
He can't.
He has to let it out.
Eh,
that that was dumb.
His apology,
that clip of it,
they showed that shit was dumb.
Yeah,
it is ridiculous.
Not An apology.
No.
The the clip.
They should excuse if it was a guy.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't make any sense anyway.
Like I said,
I don't,
I've never heard it that way.
I heard I was hurt at tiger.
Like why?
Why are you saying nigger?
Like what do you,
what is he doing?
Like why are you even hung up?
That's on him.
Yeah.
I'm 100% I did everything within my power
as it goes home.
A place,
Xbox live and he's one of the racist kids on there and then that guy was drunk a
lot too.
That's probably also part of that.
That stomach that he's got,
that shit ain't,
that ain't come and just from food guys probably lit up.
He's trying to be
funny.
Oh yeah.
Also,
he's probably trying to be funny.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean he's,
he's kind of like a comic in a sense because he's,
I'm sure he's making the cameraman laugh and the producers laugh and he's trying
to like be edgy.
Like he's got a reputation for saying sunny shit,
so he's got to live up to it.
And sometimes you're,
yeah,
no doubt man.
No doubt.
You know,
there was an article that I'm trying to find online and I can't,
we're,
we're out of time here,
goddammit.
Even Edwards,
we ran out of Goddamn time all the time with fast.
How long were you doing?
Three hours.
Hey Jesus.
I know.
That's what I'm saying,
dude.
It goes by every week like that.
It's crazy.
When a,
when are you recording your new special?
Well,
it's an album recorded it already.
Uh,
the beauty of it is there's a,
there's an article in deadline Hollywood this morning about,
it's on a Conan's label.
Oh,
beautiful.
Coming out in June.
I'm the first comic on there.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And I'm the also the first homeless comic
beyond calling chase.
But thanks chase assholes.
So it's coming out in June,
but they just released everything.
So I woke up to see that in deadline when?
In June one and June.
Uh,
probably the 10th.
Okay,
well let us know and we'll tweet it.
If you want to come back,
we'll have you on the pocket.
Come back to it.
Okay,
let's do it.
What's it called?
Uh,
it's called a hundred percent half ass.
And if you can see who's follow Ian Online.
Ian Edwards comic.
Don't fall into those other Ian Edwards.
Do Ian Edwards comic.
That's the only one.
And what's your website?
Uh,
Shit.
What's comedian.com.
Okay.
What was it was down,
so I think it's back up now.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
you got to show,
yeah,
no.
Uh,
next week,
uh,
I'm going to be in Vegas with Tony Hinchcliffe and Sarah Tiana guys or a pool
hall.
Yeah,
we're playing the backstage bar and billiards Friday,
May 16th,
8:00 PM let me know if they got good tables.
Yeah,
well yeah,
let me know if it's a good spot.
Be a great place for you to play every time you're in Vegas.
You could just say,
I got it.
I got a spot already go to.
I won't tell anybody though.
I'm fucking secretive as shit.
I moved like a ghost.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to squarespace.com go to squarespace.com enter in the code word Joe and
save yourself 10% off your first purchase and get a free trial while you're at
it.
That is squarespace.com and enter in the code word Joe.
We're also brought to you by nature box.
Go to naturebox.com/rogan and get 50% off your first box of Yummy Shit.
That's naturebox.com forward slash.
Joe.
I cannot recommend them enough.
I think there are snacks are quite yummy.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n N.
I t.
Go there,
use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
Uh,
lots of fun shit coming up.
tomorrow.
Nick Cutter,
a fine author whose book I've got right here.
I've been reading this fucking thing.
This is a great book,
man.
It's called the troop.
I got one of those a prerelease copies,
bitch.
That's right.
Was special as fuck.
And it's dog yeared cause I've been reading the shit out of it.
It's really good.
It's uh,
in the vein of like a Stephen King horror thriller and uh,
Tim Kennedy on Wednesday and uh,
uh,
Rhonda Patrick's coming in this week to kind of,
oh,
that's not this week.
Whatever,
bitch,
listen,
I got a lot of shit happening.
A Cmr big.
Wow.
Yeah.